An Easy Company, dankeschön für den Sub, Go Wizard, Pock, Subscription, exzellent, das ist sehr, oh warum ist das so leise, Moment jetzt ist das Wub Wub Wub aber viel zu laut, Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub Wub, okay, das ist das beste Plugin ever hier, Browser, Lautstärke, Regelungsplugin, das ist Massive Coggers,
Monka W, so, oh ja, ich bin noch ein bisschen später, weil ich habe heute das gemacht, was meine Garmin Uhr gesagt hat, nämlich eine Stunde 15 am Stück rennen und das habe ich auch wirklich bis auf die Minute gemacht, deswegen war ich nochmal eine Viertelstunde länger unterwegs wie sonst und ich musste zwischendurch, ey, so nach 20 Minuten rennen musste ich so krass aufs Klo und ich konnte dann nicht für eine weitere Stunde,
deswegen musste ich jetzt auch erst nochmal eine Viertelstunde aufs Klo, ich weiß, das wolltet ihr sicherlich alle wissen jetzt, deswegen bin ich jetzt erst da, aber das macht nichts, deswegen sind bestimmt auch mehr Leute wach, beziehungsweise ready zum Aufwachen,
oh, es ist echt nicht ohne, 1,15 am Stück rennen, das merkst du richtig, dass es auf die Beine geht, aber ich bin zum Glück nicht so schnell gerannt,
Ziel ist ja, demnächst mal über 20 Kilometer, ungefähr in dem Tempo wie heute wahrscheinlich, dass ich das auch durchhalte, so, ich mache mal kurz meine VM an, weil Arch, by the way, oder gibt es garantiert Updates, ja, VM, da gehen wir nicht auf den Sack,
okay, wait, übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich gesehen habe, was ich gerne, also eine Sache, die ich gesehen habe, die mich ein bisschen nervt ist, Unraid hat neue Lizenz,
irgendwas, Zeug, ich finde es jetzt gerade nicht, also ich benutze, ich benutze das ja auf meiner, auf meinem HP Microserver, weil es das ist, was mich bisher am wenigsten genervt hat, wobei ich sagen muss, großer Unraid-Fan bin ich nach wie vor nicht, auch wenn ich es benutze,
zumindest, die sind jetzt der Meinung, dass sie ihr Lifetime-License-Modell, also bisher konntest du dir, ich zeige euch mal, also bisher konnte man sich eine Lizenz kaufen, passend zum Speicherplatz,
hast du eine Basic-Lizenz gekauft für 60 Dollar, ich finde 60 Dollar quasi für Lizenz, Linus-Distribution plus Updates und letztendlich fließt da natürlich auch viel Entwicklung in das Web-Interface und alles rein, finde ich durchaus eine faire Sache und das konntest du so lange verwenden, wie du den USB-Stick verwendet hast, mit dem du die Lizenz registriert hast, das war quasi gebunden immer an den USB-Stick,
beziehungsweise an die Hardware-ID von dem Device, wo du das drauf installierst.
So, und jetzt sind sie auf die Chlor-Reihe, also ich finde, das war eigentlich recht fair bisher, ja, 60 Euro, du konntest da halt so lange benutzen, wie das Device gelebt hat, für das du es registriert hast, die Dinger leben ja auch nicht ewig, also irgendwie ab und zu mal neu, musste man sich das eh kaufen, so und letztendlich konnte man hier nur noch mehr Devices anschließen, der Rest war alles das gleiche.
Dann haben die sich gedacht, nope, das ist zu...
billig, das geht nicht, deswegen gibt es jetzt ein neues Lizenzmodell und zwar, so wie alle, ein Abo-Modell.
Und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt schon mal überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Man kann die Lizenz übertragen, okay, ich kann nicht neu kaufen müssen.
Jetzt haben sie sich gedacht, wir machen ein Abo-Modell.
Ab nächster Woche.
Ein Abo-Modell, und zwar, hey, das kleine Abo-Modell, ja, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell, das ist ein Abo-Modell.
fängt 10 Dollar günstiger an
wie das aktuelle
Lizenzmodell, aber
du kriegst plus nur für ein Jahr
Updates
danach kostet dich das 36
Dollar pro Jahr
dass du weiter, also Annual
ist jährlich, dass du weiter
Updates bekommst, das braucht
im Prinzip keiner
und jetzt die Lifetime
Lizenz
für immer Unlimited
Devices, also das was vorher Pro
war, das kostet
jetzt einfach das Doppelte
daran sieht man mal wie viel
das unterm Strich wäre, also das kostet ziemlich
genau das Doppelte
also hier, das würde
260 kosten, das kostet
250 jetzt
also das kostet das Doppelte von dem was es
jetzt gekostet hätte
also und ich muss halt ehrlich sagen, mich
fucken Abo-Modelle
einfach nur ab
überall, jeder Mist will
Abo-Modelle, du brauchst
3 Streaming-Services
Musik-Services
Backup-Services, Cloud-Services
alles wirklich
du hast ja plus die Sachen die du
du hast ja mittlerweile 30 plus
Abos, wenn du alles auf, sagen wir mal
offiziellem Wege
beziehst
betrifft das die bestehenden Lizenzen?
Nein, die bestehenden Lizenzen bleiben gleich
aber natürlich beziehen wir
immer alles auf offiziellen Wegen
wegen weil alles andere wäre ja nicht erlaubt und das übrigens auch im grunde ich habe letzten
letzten stream schon gesagt ich habe in letzter zeit total viele anime ist gekocht und das liegt
zum größten ich war früher nie der große anime cooker das liegt daran weil mir die ganzen
streaming dienste so auf den sack gehen und zum anime stream braucht es ist zwar das ist zwar
sagen wir mal grauzone aber es funktioniert gut bald kommt das ist doch schon so ist das nicht so
dass du bei bmw für firmware features abo kosten hast ich bilde mir ein ich habe da mal was gelesen
15k für abos ist natürlich schon ordentlich aber klar je nachdem was es ist das läppert sich du
denkst du immer so ja hier mal ein abo guck mal allein schon allein schon das abo was ich für die
jetbrain ideen habe ich mir vorgestellt habe ich mir vorgestellt habe ich mir vorgestellt habe ich
dies bezahle aber hier haben wir noch docker stellt ich meine allein schon das hier was bezahlt da
bezahle ich doch im jahr auch schon ja ja ein wandel bla bla pricing individual jsw so ich bin
jetzt im trainer also ich immer hier 170 euro mach da 30 euro war da irgendwie der 100 euro
immer da kommst du vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt jeder auf 15.000 euro das ist echt ordentlich ja
Aber je nachdem, was du da abonnierst, kann das durchaus sein, ja.
Das ist, dann bezahle ich für meine Fahrrad-App, bezahle ich 12 Euro, glaube ich, im Monat.
Für YouTube Premium bezahle ich Geld, wobei ich das nicht in Deutschland kaufe.
Für Prime, für, ich muss mal das mal, ich müsste mir eigentlich, ohne Scheiß,
ich müsste mir eigentlich mal, OnlyFans natürlich, keck, wait.
Nee, ich müsste mir echt mal eine Liste machen mit allen Abos, dass ich da irgendwie einen Überblick habe.
Das ist ja auch die Gefahr von dem ganzen Abo-Kram.
Du denkst dir so, ach, das kostet 15 Euro oder so, oder das kostet 5 Euro im Monat,
oder das kostet jährlich irgendwie 80 Euro und so.
Das ist doch eigentlich kein Ding, kann man machen.
Komoot für die Wande-App, die wollen auch ein Premium-Abo jetzt verkaufen und sowas in der Richtung.
Redest du oder ist das?
Das ist wirklich so.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bilde mir ein, ich habe bei BMW mal gelesen, du bezahlst bei BMW,
ja, Adobe-Abo geschickt, warum dir jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird.
Gutes Thema, passt, das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Alleine um alle Spiele für, ja, wenn man Sport gucken will, kostet das auch extreme, viele verschiedene Abos.
Du brauchst ja, wenn du alles sehen willst, glaube ich, Datsen, Premiere und noch eher?
Irgendwas? Prime?
Wenn du wirklich alles, also, wenn man wirklich so eine krasse Fußball, und das ist ja nur für Fußball,
wenn du sagen, wenn du jetzt mal irgendwie Radsport gucken willst oder so, da brauchst du ja noch mehr,
da brauchst du dann irgendwie noch hier, da ein Streaming-Service, manches wird nur von irgendeinem australischen Streaming-Service übertragen,
ganz, ganz wir, ja, also, das nervt mich, das nervt mich extrem, dieses ganze Abo-Zeug.
Ja.
Da bin ich jetzt echt zum Anime-Gucker geworden, da hast du die Probleme nicht mit Abo-Abo-Services.
So, ich mach mal kurz, Arch, by the way, Package-Updates, Docker, geh aus, jawoll, Updates, das machen wir auch aus, machen wir auch aus, brauchen wir jetzt alles nicht, Package-Updates.
Im Prinzip hat das mit den Handys schon angefangen, günstige Handys mit tollem Vertrag, ja, schon, wobei das ja immer Gerätesubventionierung noch so mit dabei war, also,
ja, aber du hast, das ging, das ging schon, das geht, das geht schon richtig, ich mein, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, viele Spiele wollen dir ja auch irgendwelche Dinger aufs Auge drücken,
da haben wir uns zwar ein bisschen wegbewegt von den klassischen Monats-Payment-Modellen, wie das früher bei MMOs am Start war,
aber die sind natürlich auch sehr daran interessiert, dass du permanent Geld reinsteckst für irgendeinen neuen Season Pass oder für irgendwelche Unlocks oder irgendwelche Cosmetics und sonst was.
Welche Docker benutzt du in deinem Unrainers?
Was? Die Frage verstehe ich nicht. Gibt es mehr als einen Docker?
So, Arch Linux, by the way.
Leute, ich hab gestern auf Twitter gefragt, ja, was würdet ihr einem 76-jährigen Rentner für einen Linux empfehlen?
Und ich war wirklich schockiert, keiner der Leute auf Twitter hat gepostet Arch Linux mit i3.
Kann ich gar nicht verstehen. Für einen 76-jährigen Rentner, der nur Windows kennt, ist Arch Linux mit i3 doch eindeutig.
Easy, easy going.
Da kann er wenigstens nichts kaputt machen, weil er nichts machen kann.
Wer nichts machen kann, kann auch nichts kaputt machen.
Also die Frage hatte tatsächlich, das war keine rein rhetorische Frage, die ich auf Twitter gestellt habe, nur für den Sinn des Fragestellens, um zu wissen, was ihr darauf antwortet.
Also meine...
Achso, Moment.
Twitter ist ja scheiße nach der Übernahme, hab ich ja vergessen.
Der zeigt mir ja nicht an, was da...
Ja, nice.
Also das hatte ich...
Ich hab mich ja gestern gefragt hier.
Wer ist das die...
Achso, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Man sieht noch nicht mal mehr die Antworten auf Twitter mittlerweile, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Wirklich?
Seit wann denn das jetzt?
Das ist aber auch neu, oder?
Also das wird echt immer beschissener.
Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Jetzt wird er übrigens auch ein Abo von mir haben, ne?
Das kommt ja noch dabei, dass viele Sachen jetzt immer mehr auf Abo umstellen.
Aber die Sachen noch immer beschissener werden.
So, und da haben die Leute alles mögliche drauf geantwortet.
Bloß nicht Archlinux mit i3.
Ich war sehr enttäuscht.
Naja, ich lösche meinen Account bestimmt nicht.
Auf X ist es jetzt ja.
Hab ich jetzt...
Leute, hab ich jetzt rebooted oder nicht?
Ich glaube, ich hab rebooted, ne?
Na, dann ist alles gut.
Ich glaube, ich hab rebooted.
Ja.
Naja, zumindest...
Ja, ich sag da gar nichts.
Das Problem ist, dass du mittlerweile so viele Abos brauchst.
Wohingegen du vor ein paar Jahren noch quasi Spotify oder Prime Music Pro,
oder wie das hieß, abonnieren musstest.
Oder Netflix oder Prime...
Irgendwann...
Musst du ja heute für Filme gucken fast schon drei bis vier verschiedene Streaming-Services.
Abonnieren.
Und da ist...
Leute, die Sport gucken wollen, waren gar nicht mit dabei.
Ja, zumindest...
Zumindest wollen die jetzt...
Oh, mal wieder zurückzukommen zu der ganzen Geschichte.
Zumindest wollen die jetzt auch umschwenken.
Umschwenken auf ein Abo-Modell.
Oh, hierzu.
Ja.
So, dass das teuerste quasi doppelt so viel kostet.
Und das finde ich kacke.
Ach ja, übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was ich auch witzig finde?
Die haben da so eine FAQ drunter.
Guckt mal.
FAQ.
Ist...
Also, Leute.
Würdet ihr sagen, dass...
Kaufen plus jährlich verlängern ein Abo-Modell ist?
Für mich klingt das verdächtig nach einem Abo-Modell.
Kaufen und dann jährlich verlängern.
Findet ihr, dass das ein Abo-Modell ist?
Also, ich finde, das ist ein Abo-Modell.
So, aber...
Unrate sagt...
Ist Unrate US a Subscription?
No.
Nein.
Kaufen und jährlich verlängern ist definitiv kein Abo-Modell.
No.
Ist kein Abo-Modell.
We don't like forced subscription either.
Das ist ja schön für euch.
Ihr müsst ja euren eigenen Kram nicht kaufen.
Und dann...
Und dann dichten sie sich irgendwie zusammen mit...
Ja, du kannst das ja ohne Updates einfach weiter betreiben.
Du musst ja gar kein Abo kaufen.
Du kannst ein Abo kaufen.
Naja.
Für mich, mit meinem Geschmack, ist das immer noch ein Abo-Modell.
Das finde ich ein bisschen kacke.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe ja hier meine Lizenz und...
Das tut schon.
Ich meine...
Wirklich glücklich mit Unrate bin ich nicht.
Ehe nicht.
Aber die Alternativen gefallen mir auch alle nicht.
Ich sehe schon kommen.
Ich lande einfach wieder auch privat auf einem simplen Debian-Server, wo ich alles selbst mache.
Wie das bei Wies4 ist, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, da gibt es aktuell keinen, der dir das gescheit erklären kann.
Weil seit der...
Was war das?
Broadcom?
Wer hat vor allem übernommen?
Broadcom, oder?
Ich glaube Broadcom.
Broadcom hat das übernommen.
Broadcom.
Da blickt keiner mehr durch, wie das abgeht jetzt mit Lizenzen, wie da was funktioniert.
Ich erst recht nicht.
Ich beschäftige mich ja hauptberuflich nicht mit Vmware.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich weiß, dass unsere Vmware-Leute da auch nicht durchblicken.
Und wahrscheinlich blickt der Vmware selbst nicht mal durch.
War bei uns auf der Arbeit auch was Lustiges letztens gewesen.
Die haben irgendeine ganz uralte Legacy-Anwendung, die auf irgendeine noch ältere Legacy, SAP, HANA, frag mich nicht, Datenbank oder...
Nee.
Oder Sybase.
Irgendwas ganz Altes.
Irgendwas ganz Altes zugreift.
So.
Und da brauchen die...
Also die Datenbank, die ist mittlerweile so fett geworden, dass irgendwie entweder...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist.
Ja, ich war da...
Ich habe das nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
Entweder ist die Datenbank so fett, dass es nicht gescheit gestort kriegen und die irgendwie auch splitten müssen.
Oder...
Dass sie das jetzt irgendwie speziell indizieren müssen, dass es irgendwie performant bleibt.
Ist auch scheißegal.
Das ist wurscht.
Jetzt gibt es ja jetzt das Ding.
Das zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder die migrieren das Ding auf Postgres und alles wäre gut.
Oder die kaufen sich für, frag mich nicht, 80.000 Euro im Jahr eine Zusatzlizenz.
Eine Extended Support Lizenz inklusive, ja, Feature Unlock Lizenz.
Damit sie das alte so weiter betreiben können, wie es ist.
Plus diesen, was zur damaligen Zeitpunkt quasi nicht offiziell supportet war.
Feature einschalten.
Zu dürfen, in der uralten Version, dass es schneller geht.
So, und jetzt dreimal dürft ihr raten, wofür man sich entscheidet.
80.000 Euro Legacy Premium Lizenz oder Postgres upgraden.
Auf Postgres umziehen.
Easy.
Ja, natürlich.
Korrekt.
Man schmeißt einfach Geld drauf.
Und hat irgendeine weitere uralte Datenbank Legacy Technologie, die man weiter betreiben muss.
Da war letztens noch irgendwas.
Fand ich auch geil.
Sie haben irgendeine Software, wo die Version nicht mehr zur Datenbank, nee, warte mal, wie war das?
Okay, lass mich mal überlegen.
Ja, genau.
Die haben irgendeine Software, die läuft gegen eine uralte Oracle Datenbank.
In dem Fall ist es Oracle, das weiß ich.
Daniel Lull, dankeschön für den Sub.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subscriptions übersehen habe, aber ich glaube nicht.
Die haben irgendeine Software, die läuft gegen eine uralte Oracle Datenbank.
Und ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie das ist.
Aber, also, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, wie es ist.
Also, ich glaube, es ist so, die, es kann sein, dass es Mist ist, was ich jetzt erzähle, aber ich glaube, so ungefähr ist es.
So, die müssen ihr Linux upgraden jetzt von Red Hat 7 auf Red Hat 8.
Also, ihr merkt, diese Systeme sind super aktuell jetzt schon.
Red Hat 7 kam raus, Moment, das ist erst vier Jahre alt.
Nee, nee, 2014, ja, das, das, das, das kommt mir realistischer vor.
2014, ja, das, das, das kommt hin.
Also, das sind Systeme wahrscheinlich, die sind wahrscheinlich noch älter von 2014.
Und da ist es jetzt so, die müssen ihre Systeme upgraden von Red Hat 7 auf Red Hat 8, weil man sieht es ja hier, Red Hat, Red Hat 7 ist, ist demnächst hier out of support.
Zumindest ist das Ding.
Die haben noch eine Anwendung drauf.
Die greift mit irgendeinem offiziellen Oracle-Client auf eine Oracle-Datenbank zu.
Und jetzt ist es so, dass die das upgraden müssen, aber auf Red Hat 8 funktioniert der alte Oracle-Client nicht mehr.
Und die Software selbst ist nur zertifiziert mit dieser alten Oracle-Version.
Das heißt, du musst dir jetzt überlegen, entweder du upgradest die Software mal.
Die da drauf läuft, damit die auch mit dem neuen Oracle-Client funktioniert.
Oder, und jetzt kommt der Hammer, oder du kaufst dir irgendeine super extended Support-Geschichte von Red Hat und Oracle, die 150.000, das ist jetzt ungelogen, Leute, 150.000 Euro im Jahr kostet.
Zusatzlizenz.
150.000 Euro.
Musst du dir mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Kostet das mehr?
Damit man das so lassen kann für noch eine Weile.
Und was macht man auch da?
150.000 Euro im Jahr ausgeben für diese komische Lizenz.
Das ist das übertriebenste Keg-Business.
Wer Keg-Business gibt, geht gar nicht mehr.
Manchmal denke ich mir auch, die haben echt so viel Geld.
Das ist wirklich so.
Das ist wirklich Pay-Per-Burn-Money.
Wir sind wirklich Meister der Legacy-Systeme bei uns in der Versicherung.
Wirklich, wo du hinguckst, wo du hinguckst, steht irgendein Uralt-System.
Die haben, wisst ihr, was ich letztens sogar gehört habe?
Von einem, die haben Solaris-Kisten noch als, oh, ich habe vergessen, wie sie das genannt haben.
Die sind quasi nicht wirklich mehr am Netz und machen nicht wirklich was.
Die sind quasi nur noch so als, ja, Archiv oder sowas vorhanden.
Solaris im Jahr 2024.
Da weiß der echt nicht mehr weiter, ey.
Ich bin nur froh, dass ich mit diesen ganzen alten Legacy-Systemen nichts zu tun habe.
Und auch jedes Mal, wenn da irgendeiner kommt und sagt, hier, Max, willst du da nicht was?
Nein, will ich nicht.
Ich mache nur halbwegs neue Sachen.
Also alles, was schon Linux ist, okay.
Und was Google Cloud und Cloud-Infrastruktur angeht, das mache ich eh am liebsten.
Da bist du nämlich gezwungen, dass es halbwegs aktuell ist.
Weil die diese sonst zwangs-upgraden oder gar nicht mehr supporten.
Naja, auf Geldautomaten läuft doch teilweise auch noch Windows.
Windows XP oder Windows 98 oder so.
Jaja.
Wir gucken uns mal übrigens gerade mal wieder an, was auf ShitHub so trennt.
Übrigens, eine Sache, wisst ihr, was auch eine Sache ist, die ich mir unbedingt im Stream mit euch mal angucken will.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt ein ESP32C4-Beatle.
Dieses Ding.
Das würde ich unglaublich gerne mal ausprobieren.
Mal gucken, ob man den Kram auch auf Amazon kriegt.
Weil.
Ah, da muss man, ach guck mal, doch, gibt es, gibt es.
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Muss man, muss man bei denen wahrscheinlich direkt bestellen.
Aber die, die, die haben auch einen Shop irgendwie, man kann das auch nach Deutschland bestellen.
Halbwegs, halbwegs gescheit.
Zumindest, warum ich mir das Ding bestellen will, ist folgendes.
Das ist ein ESP32, sag mal, ist es nicht der originale ESP32, ist der ESP32C6.
Der hat, glaube ich, kein Dual-Core und sonst was, aber scheiß drauf.
Aber, das nice ist, der hat Zigbee.
Und BLE, also BLE hat der andere ja auch.
Aber der hat neuen WiFi-Support, neuen BLE-Support und Zigbee-Support.
Beziehungsweise Thread.
Und da kann man, theoretisch damit, sein eigenes Zigbee-IoT-Gerät bauen.
Und das für 4,88.
Ich wollte nämlich schon, das ist so ein Ding, was ich seit Jahren mit mir rumschleppe, was immer nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich habe doch einen Teich hinten im Garten.
Und der droht im Winter ab und zu zuzufrieren.
Und da habe ich so einen Thermometer drin hängen, um auszulesen, wann es soweit ist, dass ich den rechtzeitig zudecken kann.
Man könnte den jetzt einfach immer zudecken, Anfang vom Winter.
Aber da sind Fische drin, die müssen ja auch nicht unnötig keine Sonne kriegen und sowas.
Oder kein Licht abkriegen.
Also, insofern, ich decke das Ding nur zu, wenn es quasi so kalt wird, dass es gefriert.
Weil, wenn man das nicht zudeckt und es gefriert, dann kann es sein, dass es am Rand platzt.
Das ist auch nicht gut.
So, und ich hatte das bisher so gemacht.
Also, ich hatte lange Zeit da einen Thermometer drin.
So einen, wie heißen diese Dinger?
DS-2818 oder sowas?
Ne, das da?
Ne, aber wie heißen diese Dinger?
DS-18B20?
Ja.
Die Dinger.
So einen Teil hatte ich da die ganze Zeit drin hängen.
An einem Zweck.
An einem zweckentfremdeten Z-Wave-Fensterkontakt, wo man Sensoren anlöten kann.
Das hat aber nie wirklich gut funktioniert mit der Kommunikation.
Obwohl ich eine Z-Wave-Steckdose hatte damals, nebendran, als Repeater.
Das hat nicht wirklich gut funktioniert.
Danach habe ich was mit BLE probiert zum Weiterleiten.
Hat auch nicht gut funktioniert.
Und das Ding ist halt, das muss dort mit Batterie laufen.
Das muss mit Batterie laufen, weil das ist halt mitten im Garten.
Da habe ich keinen Stecker.
Ja, das hilft aber nicht immer.
Ich habe so eine Pumpe.
Ja.
Aber selbst das friert teilweise zu.
Also wenn es richtig, wenn es richtig paar Tage richtig kalt ist.
Ich habe auch, ich habe so ein Ding.
Ich habe so ein Ding drin hängen.
So.
Und selbst wenn, selbst wenn, es ist nice die Temperatur zu wissen.
Und deswegen wollte ich mal ein eigenes Zigbee-Gerät bauen.
Und das scheint mir das beste Board dafür zu sein.
Kostet 5,88 Euro.
Und das ist so ein Ding.
Das ist so ein Ding.
Also deswegen wollte ich mal ein eigenes Zigbee-Gerät bauen.
Und das scheint mir das beste Board dafür zu sein.
Kostet 5,88 Euro.
Ach ja.
Und warum dieses Board genau?
Weil dieses Board ein Ultra-Low-Power ist.
Ultra-Low-Power Board.
Was nur im Deep Sleep nur 14mA braucht.
Nicht Milli, Mikro.
Und damit kann man mit so einer Handelsüber가락ung.
extracted்,
200 milliampere stunden lithium batterie oder akku kann man das ding wahrscheinlich dann
durchaus da eineinhalb jahre liegen lassen selbst wenn du plus minus 20 prozent und alles
das schwimmt schon diese diese pumpe das dass das schwimmt schon auch so ein ding da werde ich da
werde ich versuche mal so was zu bauen mini solarpanel drauf ja die idee ist die idee ist
nicht schlecht das ding ist mit einem solarpanel alleine bringt sie auch nicht das ist das wusste
ich früher auch nicht das ist gar nicht so einfach damit du mit solar laden kannst brauchst du erst
einmal logischerweise irgendein solarpanel dann brauchst du ein microcontroller der oder
oder
auch es muss kann man es muss kein microcontroller selbst irgendein kann auch eine eigene eigene
schaltung sein du brauchst ein akku und du brauchst lade elektronik dafür wenn du glück
hast hast du einen microcontroller der das integriert hat und ein batterieanschluss das
weiß ich nicht ob der so was hat also der der feier bietl hatte das der hier hat das glaube
ich nicht wenn ich bin also so produktfoto hätte man natürlich auch nicht scharf machen können das
war nicht im scope der hat doch immer aber da ist kein lade da ist kein lade dings dahinter das
ist einfach nur ein weiterer ein weiterer 3,3 volt anschluss denke ich mal so kurz echt
dann ist das eine richtig also wenn wenn er wirklich lade elektronik für den akku
trenne ist schon dann ist das ein richtig gutes allround bord für low power sachen weil dann kann
kannst du da tatsächlich
dein, äh, wobei
Battery Charging, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Damit meinen die,
dass du eine Batterie dranhängen kannst und wenn
du dann USB-Power
einstöpselst, dann lädt der die Batterie.
Der hat keine Ladeelektronik
für Solarpanels drin oder sowas.
Naja.
Lithium Battery Management?
Vielleicht doch.
Vielleicht doch, ja.
Also wenn, wenn wäre mega,
dann ist das ein richtig gutes Board.
Da muss ich mir da gleich mal welche bestellen.
Haben die auch einen deutschen Shop irgendwie?
Der Eckstein Shop, alles genau das ist.
Ähm,
wo kann ich mir dieses Ding kaufen in
Deutschland?
Computer.de
Ach,
guck mal, die haben das Teil hier auch.
Warum kostet das das Doppelte
in Euro als in Dollar?
Was ist denn das schon wieder? Anzeige ist
raus.
Ich meine, ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Moment, das ist ein, das ist ein anderes.
Das ist ein anderes.
Das ist der Fire, Fire Beetle 2.
Das ist ein anderes Board.
Das ist ein Board, wo du noch irgendwie
keine Ahnung was auch immer hast.
Ja, gut, wie dem auch sei, ich, ich muss
mir das mal in Ruhe angucken.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht im Stream.
Und demnächst müssen wir ein bisschen
Progastells machen.
Da habe ich, da habe ich richtig Bock drauf,
mal wieder ein bisschen Microcontrollerstells zu
programmieren.
Lass uns auch mal
checken,
was denn auf Shithub diese Woche so
trendet. Da freust du dich,
Progastells, ja.
Ich auch.
Was trendet denn
diese Woche so auf?
Ah,
China-Chinesen-Kram oder
Japanischer-Kram, ich weiß es nicht. Was ist das?
Es ist Auswahlübersetzung
auf Englisch. Es ist Chinesisch.
Xiang-Shang-Schuh-Notes-Comment-Crawler.
Comment-Crawler, Video-Comment-Crawler, Video-Comment-Weibu-Post-Crawler.
Ah ja, hast du den Prometheus-Exporter auf der Arbeit ausprobiert?
Eine exzellente Frage. Ja, habe ich.
Sehr gute Frage, da kann ich tatsächlich noch was
kurz zu erzählen. Habe ich ausprobiert. Und nicht nur
ausprobiert, ich habe das Ding nochmal neu gebaut, halt mit
den passenden Werten, also mit passenden Metriken, die wir
brauchen und dann richtigen API-Abfragen. Das war ja nur getestet.
im stream ich habe das ding noch mal neu gebaut ich habe ein image gebaut und in unserer test
umgebung das deployment im kubernetes cluster gepatcht so dass mein image als sidecar injected
wird und anfängt die metriken zu exportieren und jetzt haben wir ein dashboard wo block age block
id und blog timestamp drinne sichtbar ist ja es hat sich gelohnt dass wir das hier im stream
ausprobiert haben easy it's it's af ich mache so was gerne einzig dumme ist ich glaube bis auf ein
ein anderer bei mir im team oder 22 bis auf zwei andere bei mir im team geht das interessensmäßig
bei denen echt so ein bisschen vorbei die anderen sind
quasi hauptsächlich so weniger programmierer eher reine linux admins und es gibt vielleicht
zwei leute im team die sich für sowas noch interessieren außer außer mich also außer
ich deswegen erzähle ich sowas gar nicht bei uns in team runden mit custom matrix matrix
export und sonst was da musst du dir nur von manchen leuten blöde fragen anhören und dann
eine halbe stunde erklären um was es eigentlich geht da habe ich keinen bock drauf aber unsere
anwendungsverantwortlichen freuen sich extrem dass sie ein schönes dashboard haben um zu sehen
ob das ding hinterher hängt oder nicht ich muss den mal sagen muss den mal sagen ich sage ja immer man
muss nicht nur nice sachen machen man muss auch darüber reden dass man nice sachen gemacht hat
ich muss unseren anwendungsverantwortlichen mal sagen wenn die meinen chef sehen sollen sie immer
erzählen wie nice die das finden muss man muss ja immer ein bisschen darauf bedacht sein dass
es gut ankommt so wo bin ich jetzt ganz stehen
geblieben schritt habt rennt repos was verdient dein chef ich habe keine ahnung vermutlich ein
bisschen mehr aber nicht so viel mehr dass ich mir jemals den stress geben würde diesen job zu machen
zu wollen im leben nicht alter chat was mit euch los ist also aggressive freude also ich hätte keinen
bock auf ihr also ich hätte niemals bock drauf irgendwie teamleiter gruppenleiter abteilungsleiter
zutrauen allerdings dann für technik sachen und nicht für irgendwelche personal und management
verantwortungs oder projektmanagement sachen also wenn das das einzige ist womit man mehr geld
bekommen kann dann werde ich das nicht machen oder was andere suchen wo man mit technik mehr geld
verdienen kann aber glücklicherweise hat das unternehmen wo ich arbeite schon vor einer
weile gecheckt so dass du dort auch in technischer sicht möglichkeiten hast den karriere crane zu
starten wenn man auf sowas bock hat aber ihr wisst karriere client ist bei mir
bin da bin ich jeder falsche für ich mache einfach neue sachen und erzählen
den so lange dass ich neue sachen macht bis sie mir geld geben und wenn es mir
gar so lange dauert dann muss man halt mal weiter gucken
aber aktuell ist es ist es ja alles gut ja aktuell passt ja alles gibt gibt
ordentlich kohle nice home office regelungen team passt aufgaben passen
zum größten teil gibt ein paar sachen die die auf den sack gehen
also aktuell gibt es ja echt kein grund sich dazu beschweren
das ist eine richtige boomer aussage nachher weißt du was sind das die
gleichen leute die märchen steuer anstatt mehrwertsteuer sagen ich könnte
wetten das sind die gleichen leute sind solche leute die man das ja
das ist das ist so richtig das ist so ein richtiges boomer wort alter
märchensteuer ja mache ich und ich bin auch regelmäßig am flamen auf twitter
habe ich nicht home office wird bei uns immer mehr abgebaut ich wollte schon
sofort über einen monat für mein video zu dem thema machen
das ist bei immer mehr unternehmen hier return to office heißt aufhänger das
ganze wollte ich neben irgendein post von irgendeinem ceo den ich auf den ich
gar nicht mehr verstanden habe aber ich weiß nicht warum ich das jetzt so
nicht namentlich erwähnen will in meinem video weil er hat das den post
mittlerweile gelöscht der sich auch darüber aufgeregt hat wie dreist die
leute mittlerweile sind dass sie lieber home office arbeiten wollen anstatt zwei
stunden am tag hin und zurück fahren und so was ganz ganz wird wird champion post
war das er schon lange nicht mehr das liegt aber auch an mir ich habe mich ja
auch ewig nicht gemeldet ihr wisst wie wie wie wie nice ich bin im sozialen umgang
mit anderen leuten wie es gilt ich da bin zwischenprüfung war
multiple choice war war zwischenprüfer multiplisch tausche ich kann mich gar
nicht mehr in die zwischenprüfer gehabt er hat also wird es gibt
er habe er ein winter crs ein neues jahres gibt framework endlich wo man ist
das ist dass ich das welt tipp der sah nur so aus wie das welt liebt der winter
cheers
Was ist das schon wieder?
Blazingly fast
JavaScript-Server
that runs ServiceWorker-Scripts
Äh...
Moment, es ist ein
JavaScript-Service für...
Ich verstehe nicht mal,
was das sein soll.
Was im...
Was im
Server-Site, oder was? Alter, es wird
ja immer verrückter mit
Web-Geschichten.
Was im Server-Site?
Warum nicht?
Okay, mag ja durchaus Sinn machen, wenn man
das gleiche im Frontend...
Keine Ahnung. Das ist für die ganzen
Web-Entwicklungs-Stelzer...
Weiß nicht.
Hyper. Rust. Written in Rust.
Blazingly fast.
Aber so richtig verstehen den Sinn
davon tue ich immer noch nicht.
Die About-
Beschreibung ist ja auch sehr hilfreich.
Ist der Stream lagged?
Lagging? Lagging? Gerade?
Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz
sicher, was der Sinn davon ist jetzt gerade, aber
man kann
jetzt quasi Web-Assembly
Zeug auf dem Server
laufen lassen. Ich dachte immer, der eigentliche
Sinn von Web-Assembly wäre, dass man
Libraries und sowas, die
es für, sagen wir mal,
klassische Programmiersprachen gab,
die halt eher auf dem Server laufen,
auch im Browser verwenden kann und nicht
umgedreht.
Also sprich, warum muss ich beispielsweise
eine
C++-Sache,
benutzen auf dem Server
in Web-Assembly, wenn ich die doch einfach auch
direkt kompilieren kann, irgendwas, was auf dem Server läuft?
Es scheint mir auch im Hype zu sein,
ich verstehe aber gerade den Sinn davon nicht.
Ich meine, es ist Blazingly fast, written in Rust.
Allein schon,
die ganzen Krustentiere sich da dran
jetzt aufgeilen, ist klar, dass das im Hype ist.
Aber so ganz
wahrscheinlich checke ich einfach nur den Sinn
nicht richtig.
Web-Interoperable-Runtimes-Community-Group.
What?
Web-Platform-APIs
outside the Browser.
Okay, ich habe
absolut keinen
Plassen-Schimmer,
was das eigentlich sein soll,
aber es scheint
eine nice Technologie zu sein,
ohne dass ich es wirklich
verstehe.
Okay, was haben wir denn auch noch?
AI, AI, AI,
AI. Ach, guck mal,
YouTube-Downloader in Go.
Oh,
Lux.
Das Allerwichtigste, Chat,
wir müssen checken, ob Pornhub
supported wird.
Aha, aha, anscheinend,
anscheinend schon, okay.
Dann hat es ja den Zweck erfüllt.
AI, AI.
Das Ding ist,
warum ich das gucke,
wenn diese Seiten funktionieren,
dann funktionieren wahrscheinlich die meisten anderen Seiten auch.
Weil gerade Porn-Seiten
irgendwie einen,
einen Hang dazu haben,
ihren Web-Player,
so zu gestalten, dass die Videos
nur über die Seite wiedergegeben werden können,
das ist halt Werbung und alles läuft bei denen.
Ja, und die versuchen halt,
dass du möglichst nicht an die originalen
URLs drankommst. Und wenn das Porn-Seiten kann,
dann kann das so ziemlich wie jede andere Seite
wahrscheinlich auch.
Kann jemand helfen mit C++?
Eine Funktion laut Images hatte 17,
jetzt 18 Inhalte.
What? Ich verstehe kein Wort.
Vielleicht sind es jetzt einfach
18 anstatt 17 Bilder.
Ja.
So, ey,
AI, AI.
Nee, Crypto, Cryptocurrency.
Data Frames Powered by Multi-Threaded
Vectorized Query Engine.
Leute,
ich...
Wenn ihr diesen Satz läst,
versteht ihr dann,
was es ist?
Checkt
irgendjemand, was das ist?
Polar is
Pog, sagt der Friedrich Merz.
Friedrich Merz ist bekannt dafür, dass der sich,
dass der Rust Fan ist. Was genau soll das sein? Ich verstehe null anhand von diesem Satz,
was das sein soll. Ist das Art Link? Ist das paralleles Link in Rust? Oder was ist das?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus. Okay, ich habe absolut nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung davon,
was das sein soll. Warum wird AI geskippt? Weil es einen nur noch erschlägt auf GitHub.
Ah, was ist denn das hier? Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich mich trauen soll,
das aufzumachen. Ach, man kann quasi original Sachen translaten in andere Sprachen oder was?
Hm, verstehe, verstehe. Nice. Ich mache die Seite jetzt, die Originalseite nicht
aufzumachen. Ich mache die Seite jetzt, die Originalseite nicht aufzumachen.
Ich mache die Seite jetzt, die Originalseite nicht aufzumachen.
Ich mache die Seite jetzt, die Originalseite nicht aufzumachen. Weil ich nicht weiß,
was mich da erwartet, wenn ich die öffne. Die Bilder sind schon sehr sketchy. Naja,
nicht wirklich mehr sketchy als Pool-Streams auf Twitch, oder? Also, da sind Pool-Streams nur
wirklich. Eigentlich noch mehr TOS, ohne TOS zu sein. Okay, jetzt wissen wir, was auf GitHub trendet
diese Woche. So wirklich viel Spannendes war ja nicht dabei. Pool-Streams sind auch ziemlich sketch,
das stimmt, das stimmt. Habe ich jetzt vorhin schon rebooted oder nicht? Ich glaube, ich hatte
rebooted. Ich reboote nochmal, man kann nicht oft genug rebooten. Leute, ich war, ich war bei meinem
Vater am Samstagvormittag, weil er mir erzählt hat, sein Computer ist kaputt. Habe ich mir gedacht,
ach komm, lass mal gucken. Das ist mein alter Computer, den habe ich dem quasi vermacht. Also,
mein vorletzter, der Xeon Desktop. Das ist mein alter Computer, den habe ich dem quasi vermacht.
Also, mein vorletzter, der Xeon Desktop. Also, mein vorletzter, der Xeon Desktop. Also, mein vorletzter, der Xeon Desktop.
Der tut ja immer noch. Da hatte ich einfach einmal Frischwinters 11 drauf
geklatscht und hab dem das vorbeigebracht. Mittlerweile ist er natürlich nicht mehr
so Frischwindows 11 drauf, sondern, Leute, der hat so einen Scheiß installiert! Alles! So!
Ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen, was für ein Scheiß da alles drauf war. PC Cleaner
2025. Irgendwelche komischen Internet-Speedtests. Der Avira,
nehmen,
Nee, nicht Avira, äh, wie heißen die anderen, nicht Avira, äh, Avast Browser, irgendeinen Antivirus Browser hat der, Avast Browser und wirklich, es war so viel Scheiße drauf, nicht Norton, nee, irgendwas mit A, irgendwas mit A, es könnte schon Avast gewesen sein, gibt es sowas wie Avast Security Browser, gibt es sowas?
Ja, den Scheiß hat er drauf installiert gehabt, Avast Security Browser, ich wusste bis heute noch nicht mal, dass das Ding überhaupt existiert, Felix, danke schön für den Sub, da war so viel Scheiße drauf, 20 Messenger, ähm, die, die Suche war umgestellt auf Yahoo mit RevLink von PC, nicht PC Cleaner, wie heißt das Ding, PC Help?
Nee, PC, PC Cleaner, gibt es, gibt es was, was PC Cleaner heißt? PC Cleaner, gibt es sowas? Nee, das ist CC Cleaner, Helpsoft, PC Cleaner, das war da drauf, ey, so ein Scheiß, Mann, das war so voll gerotzt mit, mit, mit Dreck, der, der Rechner, ganz, ganz grausam, zumindest, also, der Rechner ging selbstverständlich noch wunderbar, was nicht mehr ging, war sein Monitor, der Monitor hat irgendwie den Geister,
aufgegeben, das dachte ich mir aber im, äh, dachte ich mir aber schon, deswegen habe ich einen neuen Monitor mitgebracht, habe den Monitor angeschlossen und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass die Grafikkarte nicht mehr richtig funktioniert, das Ding lief nur mit Windows, Windows Basic Grafiktreibern und 1280x1024, äh, Rechner von meinem Vater, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, komm, easy, easy, ich installiere einfach von, von,
von der AMD Webseite die neuesten, die neuesten Treiber und gut ist und das ging nicht, der AMD, der AMD Installer meinte die ganze Zeit, äh, Fehler beim Hardware installieren und ich wette mit euch, das liegt daran, weil da so viel Security, also, Scareware Security Scheiß im Hintergrund läuft, was der sich mittlerweile alles installiert hat, dass die Windows 11 Installation einfach schlicht und greifend kaputt ist,
ähm, dazu kommt, dass, wenn, also, als der Rechner nicht mehr funktioniert hat, hat er den Rechner mehrfach, äh, also, irgendwie gefühlt, zehnmal im Booten, äh, resettet, neu gestartet, resettet, neu gestartet, dass Windows da nicht so geil, äh, nicht so scharf drauf ist, weiß man ja auch, also, das Einzige, was ich runtergeschmissen habe, ist PC Cleaner, der Rest war mir einfach zu viel, da jetzt zu suchen und ich habe ihm gesagt, weißt du was, ich, eigentlich müsste man Windows 19,
äh, installieren und das ordentlich, das ordentlich machen, aber das mache ich heute nicht, das dauert drei Stunden, bis wir das alles, äh, wieder eingerichtet haben, habe ich heute echt keinen Nerv drauf und außerdem müssen wir deine Sachen erstmal backuppen, ich habe keinen USB-Stick dabei und so, das können wir heute nicht machen, ich muss mir das mal überlegen, musst jetzt, du musst jetzt ein paar Tage mit deinem Rechner auskommen, so wie er ist, ja, Basic, Grafiktreiber und so, ins Internet kannst du ja noch und mit deinen 26-jährigen, äh, Mädels aus der Karibik,
man muss sich das mal vorstellen, mein Vater, das habe ich euch schon mal erzählt, ne, mein Vater ist 76, glaube ich, 76 und er hat angeblich eine Freundin, die ist 26, wobei man sagen muss, der hat ja nicht wirklich eine Freundin, der hat irgendwelche, irgendeine Bekannte in der Karibik, der Dominikanischen Republik, die ihn wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ausnimmt mit Geld,
wo er monatlich Geld hinüberweist, damit die ihm schöne Augen macht, doch, doch, der schickt dir Geld, der schickt, natürlich schickt der ihr Geld, Mann, meinst du, meinst du, eine 26-Jährige aus der Karibik gibt sich mit einem 76-jährigen alten deutschen Typ ab, der, wenn er nicht Geld, wenn er nicht Geld, und mein Vater ist fest davon überzeugt, ja, das, das denke ich mir auch, Scammer getting scammed, der hat so viele, doch, doch, doch, da steckt wirklich eine Frau dahinter, der war die nämlich auch schon besuchen,
also, das, das, ich glaube, das ist Scam, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so ein, ne, ich glaube, das ist kein klassischer Roman Scam, ich glaube, das ist so eine, so eine Geschichte, so ein Zwischending aus Roman Scam und Prostitution, vermute ich mal, also, sprich, der ist ja da auch schon, der ist ja da auch, der war ja, der war ja dort auch schon und hat die besucht und alles, zumindest, was auch immer, ich habe keine Ahnung, was mein Vater da treibt,
warum man als 74-Jähriger eine 26-Jährige Freundin aus der Karibik braucht, whatever, der kann seine Rente auch ausgeben, wofür er will, ich habe ihm das schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass, der, der ist ja auch, also, ich habe ihm schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass, wenn er da kein Geld mehr überweisen würde, die halt nichts von ihm wissen will und er ist halt der Meinung, doch, doch, denen geht's da, denen, denen, die sind da anders drauf als deutsche Frauen und, ach, keine Ahnung, der ist, der ist,
als, aber halt immer noch, ja, scharf auf, äh, knackige Weiber, ja, also, naja, zumindest, er glaubt halt nicht, dass es ein Scam ist und sollte halt, er kann, soll er seine Rente, mehr, mehr als sagen, kann man es ihm nicht, soll er seine Rente ausgeben, ich war letztens mit ihm zusammen eingeloggt in seinem PayPal-Account,
ja, ey,
zumindest bei mir mit 76 noch alles funktioniert, bin ich auch happy, zumindest, ich war letztens mit ihm zusammen in seinem PayPal-Account eingeloggt, weil er da irgendwie Probleme hatte, da habe ich gesehen, es ist nicht so, dass der da ultra viel hin überweist, der überweist da immer mal wieder, so, alle, alle mal in der Woche 50 Euro oder alle zwei Wochen mal 110 Euro, der überweist da schon konstant was hin, aber es ist nicht so, als überweist er da seine komplette Rente jedes Mal hin, man darf aber nicht vergessen,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja
abonnieren und die, weiß ich
nicht, ob die Discord oder Skype oder was auch immer
verwenden. Und da fährt er auch ab und zu mal hin.
Da fährt er, glaub, weiß ich, wann
das letzte Mal war, vor einem Dreivierteljahr oder so,
war der ja in der Karibik auch.
Ist ja auch wurscht.
Soll er mit seiner Kohle machen?
Der ist unbelehrbar.
Zumindest haben sie ihm da auch das letzte Mal
irgendwie Geld geklaut und alles.
Und ach, keine Ahnung. Meine Güte.
Aber der ist unbelehrbar, was das angeht.
Ist das nicht einfach Onlyfans?
Ey, mir wäre es
lieber, der wäre auf Onlyfans.
Ja, das ist garantiert Business.
Zumindest habe ich halt zu ihm gemeint, ey, wir können das
jetzt nicht neu installieren. Das dauert wieder ewig.
Er hat ja auch gesagt, ich soll einfach alles platt machen.
Da habe ich
gemeint, ich mache garantiert nicht deinen kompletten
Rechner platt. Wenn
überhaupt, dann will ich schriftlich von dir haben,
dass du dich da auch noch in der Woche
dran erinnerst, dass du nichts von deinen Daten haben willst.
Das machen wir nicht.
Ich komme irgendwie an Ostern
mal vorbei.
Mit einem USB-Stick, da machen wir
ein Backup und
solange musst du jetzt halt
mit dem
verkackten, mit der verkackten
Windows-Installation auskommen. Du hast jetzt
wenigstens ein Monitor wieder, das funktioniert.
Hast zwar nicht die volle Auflösung, ist kacke.
Ich würde auch nicht mit dem Rechner arbeiten, aber
musst du jetzt halt mal
aushalten. Ich meine, ich habe es nicht kaputt gemacht.
Hast du selbst kaputt gemacht. Jetzt musst du auch noch ein paar
bisschen warten, bis
Ostern, dass
ich vorbeikommen kann und das machen.
Ich habe da nicht viel drauf.
95 Gigabyte, da komme ich, da nehme ich
ein USB 3 USB-Stick mit,
kopiere das rüber und dann ist gut.
So, das habe ich gesagt.
Okay, also Rechner geht wieder.
Monitor geht.
Es ist genauso kacke wie vorher.
Ich habe nur den Monitor gewechselt.
Nicht, dass du mir im Nachhinein erzählst.
Ich hätte irgendwie den Rechner kaputt gemacht oder so.
Rentner erzählen ja viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es ist genauso kacke wie vorher, nur dass du wieder ein Monitor hast,
der funktioniert. Okay, dann bin ich abgehauen
und habe mir gestern, gestern Mittag habe ich mir überlegt,
okay, doch.
Gestern habe ich mir überlegt,
ich gebe dem Temporär mein Mini-PC,
den ich mir als Emulator Rechner gekauft habe.
Ich habe doch hier so ein,
ich habe doch hier so ein Mini-PC gekauft.
Ja, so ein Mini-PC habe ich mir doch hier gekauft
und ich dachte mir, ich gebe dem Temporär.
Ich installiere einfach Linux Mint drauf auf der zweiten Platte.
Da sind ja zwei Platten drinne.
Da muss ich meinen Emulator-Kram noch nicht mal runterschmeißen.
Ich installiere den einfach auf der zweiten Platte.
Linux Mint und bringe dem den vorbei an Ostern
und nehme den anderen Rechner einfach wieder mit und sage,
weißt du was, ich brauche jetzt eine Weile,
bis ich den repariert habe.
In der Zwischenzeit kannst du das hier verwenden.
Das ist zwar kein Windows, aber du kommst drauf.
Ich habe, ich habe Teamviewer draufgehauen.
Ich habe sogar mal Rust Desk ausprobiert,
aber Rust Desk ist irgendwie noch nicht so feature complete wie Teamviewer.
Ich habe Teamviewer draufgehauen und das registriert,
dass ich Remote theoretisch sogar draufhauen kann.
Dass ich mal draufgucken könnte, wenn was ist und dachte mir so was.
Ostern bringst du ihm das vorbei, nimmst den anderen mit.
Aber ruft er mich gestern an.
Arch Linux, nein, Linux, Linux Mint mit Cinnamon habe ich draufgepackt.
Ich habe, ich habe auch nichts, nichts groß drauf konfiguriert.
Wie gesagt, außer Teamviewer draufgehauen und im Firefox U-Block Origin installiert.
Das ist alles. Also es hat nicht lange gedauert.
So und ja, gute Frage.
Den Start Button mit Restart.
Mit Rechtsklick entfernen kann.
Ja, ich habe immer noch Teamviewer drauf.
Ich kann ihm das wieder hin biegen.
Ich dachte mir so, ich stelle ihm das hin.
Der benutzt eh nur seinen Browser und da kann er auch nichts kaputt machen.
Großartig.
Zumindest ruft er mich dann gestern Mittag an.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Ja, ich fahre dahin, bringe den neuen Monitor, gucke mir das an, installiere eine Linux Kiste.
Und da sieht man mal wieder.
Booman bzw.
Booman.
Nein, Noobs helfen mit PC Support ist einfach ein.
Wie nennt man das?
Ein sehr undankbarer Job.
Er hat mich gestern Mittag angerufen, hat gemeint, er ist sehr enttäuscht von mir.
Er muss ja mal vorstellen, er ist sehr enttäuscht von mir, dass ich ihn jetzt einfach mit dem
kaputten Rechner hier habe sitzen lassen.
Und er wird sich jetzt neuen Computer online selbst kaufen und sich jemand suchen, der
ihm das installiert.
Habe ich.
Okay, da wollte ich mich erst mal aufregen.
Und habe ich.
Und habe ihn angeschissen, dass er seinen Rechner so versaut hat und es in zwei Monaten
eh wieder das gleiche ist.
Aber soll er machen?
Kein Support mehr von mir.
Dann habe ich nichts mehr mitzutun.
Ich habe gesagt Okay, mach, kauf dir das, wenn du meinst, das ist besser.
In zwei Monaten hast du das Ding auch kaputt gemacht, aber nicht mein Problem.
Und.
Das war's.
Es ist schon etwas frech, wie er das gesagt hat.
Ja, ist es, ist es, ist es.
Das Problem ist, mein Vater ist jemand, der denkt, sobald du ein-, zweimal was für ihn
gemacht hast, hat er ein Rechner drauf und darf sich dann aufregen, wenn du was nicht
machst.
Und das geht mir eh schon auf den Sack, aber ohne Scheiß, ich weiß eh, wie das laufen
wird.
Ich weiß genau, was ist.
Ich weiß.
Es gibt zwei.
Es gibt zwei Szenarien.
Er kommt sich nächste Woche an und fragt war kommst Du eigentlich vorbei und guckst
noch mal mein Computer an, so als wäre nichts gewesen.
Oder er kauft sich wirklich einen neuen Computer und dann ist er in zwei Monaten im Arsch und
fragt kannst du mal nach meinem PC gucken?
Ja.
Irgendwie, irgendwie sowas.
Das Einzige.
Ohne Mist.
Das Einzige, was man machen könnte, ist wirklich einfach ein halbes Jahr weder auf E-Mails
noch auf Telefon antworten.
Da sind wir denn.
Da sind wir dem Scheiß mal klar kommt.
Gut.
Ähm, das Gute ist, er hat kein Auto, er kann nicht, er kann nicht, ähm, er kann nicht einfach vor der Tür stehen.
Wahrscheinlich helfe ich ihm am Ende trotzdem.
Ich bin, ihr müsst wissen, ich habe euch das ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, ich bin der Einzige, der mit meinem Vater noch redet.
Der hat ja noch mehr Kinder, der hat, äh, drei Kinder, von denen man weiß, eins davon bin ich, der hat noch zwei andere.
Wie gesagt, insgesamt drei, von denen man weiß, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass der noch mehr hat.
Außerdem lügt er wie gedruckt, denkt sich laufend irgendwelche komischen Storys aus, das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Er hat in seinem Leben ultra viele Leute gescampt, weswegen er sogar seinen Nachnamen geändert hat, dass man ihn nicht mehr findet.
Er hat den Nachnamen geändert, hat eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht, dass er die Schulden los ist.
Äh, und, äh, dass ihn die Leute, die er gescampt hat, nicht, nicht mehr finden.
Könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen, was da gelaufen ist, ey?
Hast du Geschwister?
Äh, nein, nein, ich hab nur halbe Geschwister.
Die, die anderen Kinder, die er hat, sind nicht von meiner Mutter.
Ja, aber, weder von seinen anderen Kindern, noch von seiner Familie, noch von seinen Ex-Frauen, irgendjemand, oder von seinen Freunden, die er mal hatte,
noch irgendjemand will.
Niemand will was von ihm wissen, niemand, niemand redet mehr mit ihm, niemand kümmert sich um ihn, um ihn, ich mein, der hat sich, der hat ja quasi, ähm,
der hat ja quasi sein ganzes Leben darauf hingearbeitet, dass das so, dass das so ist.
Ich bin der Einzige, der noch ab und zu mit ihm hat telefoniert.
Ja, und das Problem ist halt auch, mittlerweile, also der war schon immer sehr schwierig, ja, hat immer schon immer gerne rumgeschrien, Sachen rumgeschmissen und sich, und sich bei allen Leuten unbeliebt gemacht.
Hat auch schon immer gerne Leute gescampt.
Er hat auch schon immer gerne Sachen erzählt, die nicht stimmen.
Jetzt kommt aber noch dazu, dass er alt ist und nicht mehr durchblickt.
Von meinem Vater hab ich nix geerbt.
Nein.
Also, erstens, der lebt noch, von dem hab ich nix geerbt.
Und mein Vater hat ihm, der hat nichts, was er, was der mir vererben kann.
Das Einzige, was der mir vererben wird, sind Schulden.
Und ich werd das auch nicht annehmen.
Ja, und, wie gesagt, will, will keiner, keiner mehr was von ihm wissen.
Dazu kommt jetzt noch, dass der alt ist.
Und jetzt nicht nur alles das macht, was er früher immer gemacht hat, plus, dass er jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt ist, dadurch, dass er alt war.
Ich mein, der hatte zwei Herzinfarkte schon und hat Nierenprobleme, war im Krankenhaus und alles.
Und ich bin, ich bin übrigens da, ich hab ihn aus dem Krankenhaus abgeholt.
Niemand anderes von irgendwem, der ihn kennt, hat ihn aus dem Krankenhaus abgeholt nach einem Herzinfarkt.
Ja, ist es auch.
Deswegen fällt er ja auch auf so Scammer, Scamweiber aus der Karibik rein.
100 pro, da dran liegt es auch.
Ja, zumindest, jetzt kommt noch dazu, dass er ein bisschen verwirrt ist, weil er älter ist.
Und, dass er immer mehr, also noch krasser rumlügt als früher.
Die Story mit der Entführung hab ich euch schon erzählt, die keine, die keine Entführung war.
Oder? Hab ich euch die schon mal erzählt?
Ich glaube schon.
Aber ganz kurz, nur mal für alle, die es nicht wissen.
Mein Vater hat mich eines Tages angeschrieben und meinte,
er ist in der Karibik und er wurde entführt.
Und er braucht jetzt 500 Euro Lösegeld.
Das ist, ohne Scheiß, es ist kein Witz.
Das hat er so geschrieben.
Ich, ich schmücke das nicht aus und ich übertreibe das nicht.
Das hat er eins zu eins so geschrieben.
Da denk ich mir so, okay, ich kenn ja meinen Vater.
Das heißt, ich war erstmal schon sehr misstrauisch, dass das stimmt.
Weil, weil der, weil der immer Mist erzählt.
Klingt wie ein Scammer, nur dass das dein Vater ist.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ist es, ja.
Der Witz ist, der Witz ist, immer, wenn der, immer wenn der, wenn der erzählt, sagt er,
ich hab sie alle beschissen, aber meine Familie hab ich nie beschissen.
Naja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich geh davon aus, dass der mich, dass der mich tatsächlich nicht absichtlich beschissen hat,
aber, ja, ich, der, der hatte, der hat ja auch schon mal random nen Internetanschluss in Hamburg auf meinen Namen bestellt.
Ich, auf einmal hab ich von der Telefone gehört.
Ich hab den Telekom nen Brief gekriegt.
Mein Internetanschluss in Hamburg ist nicht bezahlt.
Sie wollen das Geld.
Und ich denk mir so, hä?
Ich hab nen Internetanschluss in Hamburg?
Seit wann hab ich den denn?
Bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin, mein Vater, mein Vater hat nen, hat nen Internetanschluss abgeschlossen in Hamburg auf meinen Namen.
Und noch besser, der hat meine Unterschrift gefaked oder irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er den Vertrag unterschrieben hat.
Ich hab den nicht unterschrieben.
Hahaha.
Also, der, der Scam, na zumindest, zumindest kommen wir zu der Geschichte mit der, also,
er hat mir ne E-Mail geschrieben, er wurde entführt in der Karibik und braucht 500 Euro Lösegeld.
Und da dachte ich mir schon, okay, ich kenn meinen Vater, das ist, das stimmt bestimmt nicht.
Aber was ist denn da jetzt?
So, und die wahre, die Wahrheit war, er wurde nicht entführt.
Die Wahrheit war,
er ist in der Karibik
in ein Krankenhaus gegangen,
hat sich dort behandeln lassen
und wollte abhauen, ohne, ohne zu bezahlen.
Und da haben die dann gesagt, Herr, Herr Max Papa, sie bleiben jetzt mal schön hier,
bis sie die 500 Euro Rechnung bezahlt haben.
Weil, wenn wir sie jetzt hier rauslassen, dann sehen wir die 500 Euro ja nie.
Das Problem für ihn war nur, der hatte keine 500 Euro.
Hahaha.
Und wisst ihr, da sieht man mal schon wieder, dass der sie nicht mehr alle hat.
Hätte der mir geschrieben, ja, hätte der mir geschrieben, Max,
ich sitz in der Karibik fest, weil ich im Krankenhaus war,
ich muss ne Rechnung von 500 Euro bezahlen, sonst lassen die mich hier nicht weg,
hab ich aber grad nicht, kannst du mir helfen?
Der flucht der Karibik.
Hahaha.
Da hätte ich ihm das auch, dann hätte ich ihm natürlich,
ich hätte die Rechnung bezahlt und gut wär gewesen, ja.
Und, aber er hat gedacht, er muss irgendwie sich ne komische Entführungsstory ausdenken,
die nicht stimmt.
Und das ist halt das Ding, der könnte eigentlich bei den meisten Sachen
näher bei der Wahrheit bleiben und man würde ihm trotzdem helfen,
aber dadurch, dass der sich dann so krasse Sachen ausdenkt und einen anlügt,
glaubst du ihm nichts mehr, du glaubst ihm kein Wort.
Und das ist halt das Ding, du kannst ihm nichts glauben.
Naja, also wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt darauf gekommen bin,
zumindest, es ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Also, ich glaube, viele Leute haben anstrengende Eltern, ja,
aber ich glaube, mit meinem Vater hab ich schon echt eine Ausnahmeform von anstrengenden Eltern.
Mein Vater hat einfach das Scammer-Crime-Set.
Hat er auch, hat er auch.
Mein Vater ist ein Scammer durch und durch.
Der bezahlt ja aus Prinzip auch nichts.
Ich hab auch keine Rechnung.
Ich hab letztens dem seinen Briefkasten ausgeleert.
Und ohne Scheiß, da kam ein Stapel, wenn ihr so eine Faust macht, ja,
so dick, ja, das ist jetzt eine Blöde, so dick wie der Arm,
kam da ein Stapel an Briefen und das waren alles irgendwelche Inkassoschreiben
von irgendwelchen Dingern, woran irgendwo mal was gekauft hat, nicht bezahlt hat.
Und er sagt zu mir, ach, schmeiß die Dinger weg, ich mach die eh nicht auf
und bezahlen du auch nichts.
Weil, und jetzt kommt die Erklärung, bezahlen tut er nichts, weil, das ist aber wortwörtlich,
Zitat, das geht ja gegen seine Prinzipien, was zu bezahlen.
Da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, oder?
Der Kerl, Alter.
Ach ja, und mal davon abgesehen, ich hab mal streng genommen auch keinerlei Verpflichtung,
nur weil es mein Vater ist, dort für den überhaupt irgendwas zu machen, ja.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte der sich groß um mich gekümmert,
beziehungsweise als wäre er seinen Pflichten nachgekommen.
Der hat meine Mutter sitzen lassen.
Er hat meine Mutter sitzen lassen, wo ich, frag mich nicht, eins, zwei Jahre alt war
und hat so gut wie nie Unterhalt bezahlt, bis ich dann erwachsen war.
Also eigentlich hat er nichts gemacht, im Prinzip ist er abgehauen
und hat sich dann nicht drum, obwohl der mehr als genug Geld hat damals,
weil damals hatte er noch sein Scambusiness in Frankfurt am Start,
seine Partnervermittlungsagentur.
Ich meine, das, was heute im Internet gemacht wird,
auch Leute gescampt wird, hat er damals offline gemacht.
Hat auch ganz viele Leute gescampt, allerdings legal.
Der hat die legal gescampt.
Die haben halt Verträge unterschrieben, wo man sich fragt, ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
mein Vater, den haben sie ja angezeigt, da stand er sogar vor Gericht,
wegen dieser ganzen Geschichte, die er da abgezogen hat.
Der wurde freigesprochen.
Also, muss sagen, offiziell ist mein Vater kein verurteilter Scammer oder so.
Der wurde freigesprochen, weil er so gute Verträge gemacht hat.
Und es muss wohl in der Verhandlung so gewesen sein, dass einer der,
ich weiß nicht, ob es der Richter war oder sonst was,
der muss eine der Klientinnen damals wohl wirklich wortwörtlich gefragt haben,
wie kann man so einen Vertrag unterschreiben.
Es war quasi so der komplette Freibrief, der Vertrag, den die da unterschrieben haben.
Also, da konnten sie eben keinen Strick draus drehen.
Der ist freigesprochen.
Aber der hat schon das krasse Scammer-Mindset.
Ja.
Naja, gut.
Okay.
Ja.
Und damals hat er richtig fett Kohle verdient, ja.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das muss so im Dreh gewesen sein 1990 rum.
1980, also ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das muss so 1988, 89, 90, 91, 92, 93 rum gewesen sein.
So in der Zeit.
Und in den paar Jahren, da hat der Typ richtig krass Kohle gemacht.
Der hatte mehrere 10.000, ich wollte gerade sagen Euro, waren es ja damals noch nicht.
Der hat mehrere 10.000 Mark im Monat auf der hohen Kante gehabt durch sein Scambusiness.
Der hätte mehr als genug Geld gehabt, Unterhalt zu bezahlen.
Hat er aber nicht gemacht.
Moin.
Und die Aussage meiner Mutter damals gegenüber war, das hatte mir, das hatte mir, klingt sehr verantwortungslos.
Ja, er ist die Verantwortungslosigkeit in Person.
Scam und Verantwortungslosigkeit in Person ist er.
Meiner Mutter hat er damals wortwörtlich gesagt, er kann erst Unterhalt bezahlen, nachdem er 10.000 Mark im Monat für sich hat.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja.
Du hast deine Ex-Frau sitzen lassen mit dem Kind.
Und sagst, du kannst keinen Unterhalt bezahlen.
Du kannst erst Unterhalt bezahlen, wenn du mindestens 10.000 Mark für dich im Monat hast.
Allein schon, allein schon, als du auf so eine Aussage kommst.
Der hat das richtige Crimeset-Mindset am Start gehabt.
Und daraufhin ist meine Mutter ja damals zum, frag mich nicht, zum Amt, zur Polizei oder ich weiß es nicht, was das war.
Und die haben dann quasi...
Das bezahlt für den in Vorkasse und haben dann versucht, das Geld von dem quasi zu fänden, sozusagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man dieses Verfahren nennt.
Und da hat er sich dann auch versucht, quasi der Sache zu entziehen und so.
Und hat einfach nichts bezahlt.
Alter, ganz, ganz grausam.
Heute, ohne Scheiß, wenn mein Vater heute in dem Alter wäre, wie damals, wo er sein Business am Start hatte,
dass der hätte so ein Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Ding.
Dass der hätte so ein Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Ding.
Der hätte heute Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Motivations-Business-Coaching, hätte der heute.
Garantiert.
Mein Vater ist genau so ein Typ, der heute so ein Business-Coaching machen würde.
Danke, dankeschön für den Sub.
So, jetzt habe ich aber lang genug über meinen Vater und Verwandtschaft und mich erzählt.
Wir gucken uns mal ein paar YouTube-Videos an, um die Stimmung aufzunehmen.
Heute, der hätte garantiert Komm-in-die-Gruppe, hätte der.
Schlauer Hase Insi.
Mein Vater hat den Insi-Modus durch.
Der hat eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht vor ein paar Jahren.
Nachdem er witzigerweise seinen Nachnamen geändert hat,
dass ihn die Leute von früher nicht mehr finden.
Also, da wisst ihr schon Bescheid, was seine Sache ist, ja?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der hat drei Kinder.
Das heißt nicht, dass der für drei Kinder Unterhalt bezahlt hätte.
Für mich hat er keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Und für seine anderen zwei Kinder hat er garantiert, hundertprozentig,
auch keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Namensänderung private Zahn.
Ja, könnt ihr euch auch vorstellen.
Das ist, das ist wirklich, mein Vater ist der klassische
Comedy-Gruppe-Mindset-Lifestyle-Coach von heute.
Nur, dass es damals halt ein anderes Business war.
Aber heute würde der exakt sowas machen.
Kennst du die anderen Geschwister?
Welche? Meine Halbgeschwister?
Nee, die kenn ich nicht.
Also, ich kenn die von Bildern und so,
und die kennen mich auch von irgendwelchen Fotos und so.
Aber wir hatten nie großartige, wie soll ich sagen, ja,
Ambitionen, uns kennenzulernen.
Da kann ApoRed definitiv noch was lernen.
Der hat das schon durchgespielt, da gab's ApoRed noch nicht.
Gut, also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
Brainchips.
Stimmt, was ist da eigentlich draus geworden?
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Was ist das?
Fuck.
Polizeieinstellungstest.
Okay, Leute.
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Wir hatten jetzt,
wir hatten jetzt so viel Low-Brain-Kontext,
wir brauchen jetzt High-IQ-Kontext.
Okay, Polizeieinstellung, da geht nur 2 Minuten 23,
kann nicht so kompliziert sein.
Okay.
Generelles und Aufgabe.
Okay, Chat.
Jetzt will ich hier sehen von euch,
was die ganzen Subscriptions gebracht haben,
wie hoch der Chat-IQ ist.
Wenn wir nicht mindestens 90% die richtige Antwort hier im Chat kriegen,
dann muss ich meinen Channel löschen.
Nee, lieber nicht.
Dann bauten die Leute,
dann bauten die Leute absichtlich falsch.
Dann passiert nichts, außer dass ihr Low-IQ seid.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal die Aufgabe erklären.
Figuren einsetzen.
Hier haben wir die Aufgabe.
Du sollst dir also aus den gegebenen Figuren einmal entscheiden,
welche Figur A, B, C oder D das Fragezeichen sinnvoll ersetzt.
Ich geb dir ein bisschen Zeit, damit du dieses Video pausieren kannst.
Easy.
Okay, Umfrage.
Umfrage.
Was ist so wichtig?
A. B. C. D.
Ihr könnt euch das kurz überlegen.
Und ich sage euch gleich, was ich da ...
Das ist easy as fuck.
Abstimmung Leute.
Mal gespannt.
Du siehst D nicht?
Ja, Moment.
Ja, YouTube suckt ein bisschen mit dem Overlay.
D ist so ein Pac-Man.
A, B, C, D.
Okay, was haben wir?
Manche sagen A, manche sagen C, Mehrheit sagt D.
Keiner sagt B.
Ach, der Chat war davor.
Ups.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe mit euch d'accord.
Ich denke auch, dass es D ist.
Weil das Quadrat hier oder das Rechteck,
ist auch egal,
das wird quasi zur Hälfte gekippt nach rechts.
Und wenn man diesen halboffenen oder diesen vierteloffenen Kreis
zur Hälfte nach rechts kippt, dann kommt D raus.
Ah, Soso, du hast recht.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, ihr habt, Chat, Chat, ihr habt recht.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Es könnte genauso gut nach links gekippt sein.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja.
Macht das einen Unterschied?
Was ist mit dem Abo?
Oh, das müssen wir gleich gucken.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Wir wissen nicht, ob,
links rum oder rechts rum.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
es wird auf jeden Fall nur halb gekippt.
Und halb gekippt kann nicht das sein.
Egal, wie du es drehst und wendest.
Es kann nicht das sein, nicht das.
Es kann eigentlich nur D sein.
Aber muss es eine 45 Grad Drehung sein?
Naja, am meisten sind ja diese Aufgaben,
finde das untere, was entsprechend zu dem oberen passt.
Also, ich weiß nicht,
ob es 45 Grad sind, exakt, aber es sieht halt halb gekippt aus.
Ja, es wurde zur Hälfte gekippt und das muss man auch zur Hälfte.
Egal, gucken wir, was rauskommt.
Also, generell ist es bei diesen Aufgaben so, du hast eine obere Reihe.
Ja, ich will einfach wissen, was rauskommt.
Da haben wir nämlich einen schwarzen Kreisausschnitt.
Wenn wir genau das gleiche machen müssen wie oben, bedeutet das,
okay, da muss die gleiche Figur hin.
Aber diese Figur muss einfach.
Vielleicht wurde es auch 315 Grad nach links gedreht.
Das kann sein.
Aber dann würde.
Keines passen von den hier unten.
Also von der Lois kann eigentlich nur D sein.
Einfach um 45 Grad gedreht werden.
Das bedeutet, wir suchen jetzt hier einen schwarzen Kreisausschnitt,
der auch um 45 Grad gedreht ist.
Und wenn uns das einmal klar ist, dann wird schnell klar,
dass die die einzig richtige Lösung.
Easy Chat.
Ich bin begeistert von euch.
Ihr wisst Bescheid.
Kreisausschnitt A ist um.
High IQ Chat gedreht.
Kreisausschnitt B ist um 90 Grad gedreht und Kreis.
Ja, okay.
Bleib ihm.
Ähm.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert, wenn es nicht D ist.
Wenn man solche Dinger hat, verkackt man es ja ab und zu auch mal ganz gerne.
Aber das war obvious.
So, was wollte ich mir noch angucken?
Warum dir jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird?
Okay, die die kurze Erklärung, ohne das Video zu gucken, ist, weil es mir Geld bringt.
Ja, Leute, die Bewerbung Bewerbung Polizei ist raus, oder?
Und davon abgesehen, ich würde im Leben nicht bei der Polizei arbeiten wollen.
So.
Ja, warum?
Gucken wir uns das an.
Ja, das passt ja wunderbar zum Stream.
Habe ich mich am Anfang auch schon drüber beschwert, dass es für jeden Scheiß ein Abo braucht.
2013 im Headquarter des amerikanischen Software.
Adobe Adobe.
Ich habe das früher immer Adobe ausgesprochen, aber die coolen Leute sprechen das natürlich Adobe aus.
Manche sagen auch Adobe.
Leute Adobe Adobe Adobe.
Sagen die eigentlich offiziell, wie sie heißen?
Oder ist das Interpretationsraum?
Wie herrscht Anspannung pur?
Es ist der wohl wichtigste Tag in der 31-jährigen Unternehmensgeschichte.
Denn an diesem Tag trifft Adobe eine radikale Entscheidung.
Musik im Hintergrund, Alter.
In Zukunft will das Unternehmen seine Produkte nicht mehr verkaufen, sondern nur noch in einem monatlichen Abo anbieten.
Allen ist klar, geht dieser Plan schief, dann steht das hochprofitable Unternehmen vor dem Abo.
In diesem Video erzählen wir euch die Story von einem der riskantesten Business Moves der jüngeren Wirtschaftsgeschichte.
Und wie dieser die Welt für immer verändert hat.
Das hier ist Shantanu Narayan.
Amerikanische Tech-Medien bezeichnen ihn immer wieder als Genie.
2011 holt ihn sogar Barack Obama als Berater in sein Team.
Ich kenne ihn nicht. Kanntet ihr den?
Er ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt seit 6 Jahren im Team.
Und damit auch Schlüsselfigur in dieser absolut verrückten Adobe-Story.
Okay, wait. Jetzt kann es vielleicht sein, dass ihr noch nie von Adobe gehört habt.
Ein Produkt kennt ihr aber safe.
Photoshop.
Und zwar folgendes.
Ja, das ist Photoshop-Philip.
Er hat's nicht so mit Menschen.
Aber er beherrscht Photoshop wie kein zweiter Photoshop-Philip.
Richtig. Adobe ist das Unternehmen, das hinter zum Beispiel Photoshop oder After Effects steht.
Und das ist das Unternehmen, das hinter Photoshop oder After Effects steht.
Und das ist das Unternehmen, das hinter zum Beispiel Photoshop oder After Effects steht.
Also genau die Programme,
ohne die ich so wichtige Dinge wie das hier
nicht machen könnte.
Adobe steht so ziemlich hinter jedem Programm,
mit dem Conent produziert wird.
InDesign, After Effects, Premiere, Acrobat,
Flashplayer
und noch rund 50 weitere Programme
hat Adobe 2013 im Sortiment.
Selbst dieses Video hier wurde nur mit Adobe-Programmen gemacht.
Grüße gehen raus an unsere Katharine Carey.
Mit Photoshop und Co. hat Adobe damals bereits richtig viel Kohle verdient.
Schaut mal, zwischen 2002 und 2012 ist der Umsatz des Unternehmens mit einer Ausnahme jedes Jahr gewachsen.
2012 hat Adobe einen Umsatz von fast 5 Milliarden Dollar gemacht.
Und dann gehen Anfang der Zehnerjahre auch noch Social Media Plattformen wie Instagram, YouTube oder Pinterest komplett durch die Decke.
Also alles Plattformen, für die Bildbearbeitungssoftware aka Photoshop gebraucht wird.
Kurz gesagt, Adobe sitzt 2012 mit seinen Programmen auf einer Goldgrube.
Und das heißt in Zahlen, das Unternehmen macht 2012 einen fetten Gewinn von einer Milliarde Euro im Jahr.
Läuft also für Adobe.
Da lacht sich Apple ja kaputt.
Und zwar Shantanu Narain, ihr erinnert euch, der CEO von Adobe.
Er ist sogar so unzufrieden, dass er das gesamte Geschäftsmodell seiner Firma verlässt.
Und das hat vor allem einen Grund.
Und zwar diese CD hier.
Mit der hatte Narain drei fette Probleme.
Das erste ist, sie war verdammt teuer.
Wer alle Programme von Adobe nutzen wollte, musste für die CD etwa 2000 Dollar auf den Tisch legen.
Vor allem Hobby-Fotografen haben sich damals also mindestens zweimal überlegt, ob sie sich so ein riesen Investment leisten wollen.
Der zweite Grund, die waren einfach übel leicht zu kopieren.
An kopierten CDs verdient Adobe natürlich nichts.
Warum hat das Cagway-Business im Hintergrund, warum ist das nicht freigestellt, das Bild?
Was ist da?
Ich glaube, wir brauchen eindeutig Background-Removal-AI dafür jetzt.
Und drittens, naja, CDs waren halt damals schon ziemlich uncool.
Hoppla! Legt die CD...
Ist ja gut, ey.
Den CDs, und zwar für immer.
Narains Plan...
Der hätte das ja auch einfach downloaden können, ohne CD.
In Zukunft will das Unternehmen seine Produkte nicht mehr verkaufen, sondern verleihen.
Am 6. Mai 2013 veröffentlichte Adobe folgende Pressemitteilung.
Neue Produktinnovationen werden ausschließlich über Adobe Creative Cloud bereitgestellt.
Statt einmalig 2000 Dollar müssen Adobe-Kunden in Zukunft 50 Dollar im Monat für einen Zugang zu der Cloud zahlen.
Es ist eine Nachricht, die in der Business-Welt einschlägt wie eine Bombe.
Was kostet das aktuell?
Warum hat mir Noah Leidinger vom Podcast Ohne Aktien wird schwer erklärt.
Noch ein Risiko war auch, dass dieses normale Geschäft ja sehr gut gelaufen ist und auch sehr attraktive Margen hatte.
Und es hätte halt auch sein können, dass die Kunden sagen, nee, wir wollen nicht so eine regelmäßige Gebühr haben.
Das, was Noah da sagt, heißt in anderen Worten, Adobe-CEO Narain setzt mit seiner Entscheidung die Zukunft seiner 10.000 Mitarbeiter aufs Spiel.
Ja, als würde er sich für die Mitarbeiter interessieren.
Scene TechCrunch titelt deshalb Adobe Goes All In.
Und erstmal scheint es so, als wäre dieser Move die dümmste Idee der Wirtschaftsgeschichte.
Denn kurz nach der Pressemitteilung sieht es so aus, als ob der Move komplett nach hinten losgeht.
Denn die Kunden reagieren erstmal so.
Ja, das ist ja normal. Es wird immer rumgeschrien erstmal und dann gewöhnt man sich dran und dann geht es sogar noch weiter hoch.
Ich habe letztens gehört, dass World of Warcraft angeblich wieder mehr Abonnenten hat als in der Primetime, also in der Zeit von vor ein paar Jahren, wo sie so super krass am Start waren.
Natürlich ist das ein bisschen unfair zu vergleichen. Heute ist Gaming viel, viel Mainstreamiger.
Und das Game ist sehr auf, wie soll man sagen, so Fear of Missing Out und sowas ausgelegt.
Mehr als früher.
Aber die Stonks rollen.
Okay, ich sage es mal so. Adobe's Kunden sind nicht gerade glücklich mit der Umstellung aufs Abo-Modell.
Fast 50.000 Menschen unterschreiben sogar eine Petition, dass Adobe die Umstellung wieder rückgängig machen soll und zwar sofort.
In der Petition heißt es, Adobe beraubt kleine Unternehmen, Freiberufler und den Durchschnittsverbraucher.
Und der US-amerikanische Star-Fotograf David Hobby schreibt sogar,
Aber das fühlt sich an wie der größte Geldraub in der Geschichte der Software.
Okay, what?
Der größte Geldraub der Geschichte, das hört sich erstmal nach einem ziemlich krassen Vorwurf an, über den müssen wir später nochmal sprechen.
Weniger emotional reagieren auf...
Die Leute waren damals einfach pepega.
Also Petitionen bringen überhaupt nichts.
Bob hätte mal wieder eine Army bilden müssen gegen Adobe. Das hätte bestimmt funktioniert.
Auf jeden Fall die Investoren. Die interessieren sich nur für die Zahlen.
Falls sich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern kann.
Bob bildet eine Army. Gegen was hat Bob nochmal die Army gebildet?
Google+. Google+, oder?
Ja, ja, Google+. Bob war gegen Google+.
Und die Zahlen brechen erstmal ein. 2012 hat Adobe ja noch einen fetten Gewinn von einer...
Bob hat langfristig gewonnen, aber nicht durch seine Army.
Bob hat durch Aussitzen und Unfähigkeit von Google gewonnen.
...Milliarde Dollar gemacht.
Ein Jahr später, also kurz nach der Umstellung auf das Abo-Modell, bricht der Gewinn einfach um die Hälfte ein.
Für Noah Leidinger ist das aber auch kein großes Wunder.
Und erstmal muss man ja auch Geld in Marketing investieren, um das neue Abo-Modell bekannt zu machen, um Kunden zu überzeugen, dass sie da hinwechseln sollen.
Und das hat natürlich auch auf die Gewinnmargen gedrückt.
Was Noah damit meint...
Und das erste halbe Jahr oder das erste Jahr ist ja auch eine ganze Ecke günstiger, als den Vollpreis zu bezahlen.
Du kannst quasi für ein Viertel des Vollpreises damals das Abo abschließen.
Dafür ist es langfristig gesehen viel mehr Stonks.
Das Abo-Modell war verdammt teuer.
Denn neben teurem Marketing musste Adobe zum Beispiel auch viel Geld in seine Creative Cloud investieren und die eigenen Abteilungen umstrukturieren.
Und da muss man wirklich auch mal den Hut vor denen ziehen, das scheinen sie ja ganz gut hinbekommen zu haben.
Ich habe kein Creative Cloud Abo, deswegen kann ich das nicht aus erster Hand berichten.
Also erstens muss man diesen Move erstmal machen und das muss dann auch funktionieren.
Weil stellt euch mal vor, es hätte nicht nur diesen riesen Shitstorm gegeben am Anfang, so nach dem Motto Abo-Modell, alles scheiße und sonst wie.
Stellt euch mal vor, die hätten das umgestellt und das Subscription Creative Cloud Abo hätte nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was meint ihr, wie groß dann das Geschrei gewesen wäre?
Aber davon hörst du ja so gut wie nichts. Also das scheint ja echt ganz gut zu funktionieren.
In anderen Worten heißt das, mit der Umstellung auf das Abo-Modell ist Shontano Narayan eine ziemlich riskante Wette eingegangen.
Eine Wette, die sich auf zwei Worte herunterbrechen lässt.
Wiederkehrende Einnahmen.
Und auf diese wiederkehrenden Einnahmen setzt...
Er hat einfach das richtige High-Performer-Mindset am Start gehabt.
...Narayan nun alles.
Top. Die Wette gilt.
Alle Rätsel über den abenteuerlichen Move von Adobe. Nur einer behält komplett die Ruhe.
Es ist Shontano Narayan. Denn der hat den Umsatz- und Gewinneinbruch, den wir uns im letzten Kapitel angeschaut haben, längst einkalkuliert.
Er glaubt fest an den Abo-Move. Und naja, was soll ich sagen? Schaut euch einfach mal die Zahlen an.
Den Umsatz von Adobe vor dem Abo-Move, den kennt ihr.
Was aber danach abgeht, ist einfach nur crazy.
Mit dem Abo-Modell hat sich der Umsatz von Adobe einfach verwirrt.
Stonks. Ultra-Stonks.
Mittlerweile stammen über 90% des Umsatzes aus den Abo-Einnahmen.
Hyper-Stonks.
Das seht ihr an den gelben Balken hier. Narayans Wette ist also komplett aufgegangen.
Oh, diese Einspieler sind super cringe, Mann.
Das hat für die Adobe-Programme ja ungefähr 2000 Dollar gekostet.
Mit den Abos zahlen Kunden jetzt aber 50 Dollar im Monat, beziehungsweise 600 Dollar im Jahr.
Das heißt konkret, behält ein Kunde das Abo länger als vier Jahre, dann verdient Adobe jetzt mehr mit ihm als mit den CDs.
Und diese Langzeit-Nutzer sind halt weg. So, ich kauf mir das und benutze es dann zehn Jahre.
In der Umstellung hat man gesehen, dass nicht nur der Umsatz massiv gestiegen ist von Adobe langfristig, sondern vor allem, dass die Margen dann auch nochmal viel besser waren.
Was das in konkreten Zahlen heißt, zeige ich euch nochmal an der Grafik.
2022 hat Adobe mit Photoshop, InDesign und Co. nämlich einfach mal einen Gewinn von 6 Milliarden Euro gemacht.
Also ungefähr sechs Mal so viel wie noch 2012 zu CD-Zeiten.
Schon verrückt, oder? Wie zur Hölle konnte das Abo-Modell so krass einschlagen?
Das erzähle ich euch jetzt mal am Beispiel von meinem Kumpel Tommy.
Der Tommy ist nämlich seit kurzem Design-Stu...
Oh, das muss ich mir jetzt wieder angucken. Eigentlich wissen wir doch schon...
...einen Game-Changer und erobert von nun an die Welt.
Erfinder des Abo-Modells im Software-Bereich war übrigens nicht Adobe, sondern eine ganz andere Firma, und zwar Salesforce.
Die verkaufen ihren Software aber ausschließlich an Unternehmen.
Nachdem Adobe ab 2013 bewiesen hat, dass das Abo-Modell auch im Privatkundengeschäft funktioniert, breitet sich der Abo-Hype in der gesamten Tech-Branche aus.
Microsoft Office, Zoom, Snowflake, Asana...
Wait, Zoom? Da kann man Abo für abschließen?
Ich bin der übelste Kack-Noob. Das sagt mir was, was übrigens gar nicht mal Microsoft Office heißt.
Aber das ist zweitrangig. Zoom kenne ich auch, aber was ist Snowflake und Asana?
...größte deutsche Software-Unternehmen SAP. Mittlerweile setzen fast alle großen Software-Konzerne auf Abo-Modelle.
In der Tech-Szene ist das Business-Konzept mittlerweile so stark...
Gibt es eigentlich irgendjemand, der SAP mag, außer SAP Consultants?
Und ich glaube noch nicht mal SAP-Consultants mögen SAP. Ich glaube, die mögen die Kohle, die man damit machen kann. Privat haben die aber da auch keinen Bock drauf.
...stark verbreitet, dass es dort jetzt einen eigenen Namen hat. Software as a Service.
Und dieses Modell ist so erfolgreich, dass gerade so ziemlich jede Branche auf den Hype mit aufspringt.
Spotify, Netflix und Amazon Prime werden die meisten von euch ja noch kennen, aber...
Bei dir in der Firma mögen viele SAP Kunden.
...die und ABAP. Haben die irgendwie geistig irgendwelche Probleme oder wie kommt's?
Kein Witz, mittlerweile werden sogar Windeln, Weine und sogar Blumensträuße im Abo vertickt. Schon wild, oder?
Bei Amazon, wenn ich Katzenfutter bestellt habe oder Zahnpasta oder letztens habe ich Interdentalbürsten bestellt bei Amazon.
Das ist jetzt was, was nicht so oft gekauft wird hier, ja.
Talbürsten.
So was habe ich bestellt bei Amazon.
So hier, also.
Was sind denn meine?
Was sind nicht?
Hier, so was hier zum Beispiel, ja.
Curaprox.
So, und wenn man die jetzt versucht zu kaufen bei Amazon,
dann sagt Amazon, möchten sie das Ganze als Abo...
Ah, okay, ich bin nicht eingeloggt, ja.
Amazon sagt, möchten sie das jetzt als Abo bestellen.
Darf ich auch...
Wie jetzt?
Zahnbürstenabo?
Ökonomen nennen diese Abo-Flut übrigens...
Hast du schon mal Proxmox auf einem Hetzner-Root-Server installiert?
Nee.
Aber ich stelle mir das nicht so unterschiedlich vor zu anderen Systemen.
Was ist da alles im Warenkorb?
Das ist eine sehr berechtigte Frage.
Ich weiß es auch nicht mehr.
Interdentalbürsten?
Äh, Pferdesalbe, USB-Sticks, Mount für mein Fahrradstell-Kram.
Äh, ja.
SAP-Software zu administrieren, pain as fuck, das denke ich mir.
Ja, Rasierklingen-Abo und so was.
Das Blöde ist, dass Amazon oftmals, wenn du Produkte neu bestellst,
diesen Abo-Ding als Default-Kaufoption auswählt.
Da musst du wirklich genau gucken und sagen,
nein, nein, einmal Kauf.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Was hast du denn für ein Problem mit deinem Hetzner-Server?
Subscription Economy.
Und die wird sich sehr wahrscheinlich noch viel stärker ausbreiten.
Schaut mal.
Diese Kurve zeigt, wie sich die Umsätze der größten US-amerikanischen Unternehmen
in den letzten 10 Jahren entwickelt haben.
Toilettenpapier im Abo gibt es garantiert.
Und diese Kurve hier zeigt, wie sich die Einnahmen der...
Warum Unraid offen ist?
Weil Unraid jetzt auch Subscription macht.
Obwohl sie offiziell...
Ich will nicht sagen, dass sie Subscription machen.
... Unternehmen entwickelt haben, die auf Abo-Modelle setzen.
Die sind einfach viermal so stark gestiegen.
In den USA hat die Abo-Flut also ziemlich krasse Ausmaße angenommen.
Laut einer Studie zahlt der durchschnittliche Amerikaner
fast 220 Dollar für Abonnements.
Für Deutschland gibt es dazu leider noch keine Zahl.
Das krieg ich aber auch hin.
Besonders interessant ist dabei aber eine andere Zahl.
Denn die Studie hat auch herausgefunden,
dass 84% der Amerikaner ihre Abo-Ausgaben unterschätzen.
Und genau das...
Im Monat, im Monat.
... ist auch die Gefahr, die unser Experte Noah Leidinger in der Abo-Flut sieht.
Ich glaube schon, dass viele Leute sehr viel für Subscriptions ausgeben.
Alter, da musst du jetzt so wirklich kein Experte für sein,
um zu erkennen, dass du da schnell den Überblick verlierst, oder?
Eben, das oft auch gar nicht mehr so im Blick haben,
weil halt die einzelnen Kosten relativ klein sind.
Und da kommen dann schnell mal Kosten von 50 Dollar im Monat zusammen,
obwohl man immer nur so kleine Verträge abschließt.
Teilweise nimmt das ziemlich absurde Ausmaße an.
BMW zum Beispiel hat 2022...
Wenn ein Hootserver bei Hexer nicht mal startet,
musste über...
Musste in diese komische...
Wie heißt das bei Hexer?
Recovery-Konsole oder so?
Kann man bei Hootserver mit Hexer nicht die Grafikausgabe redirecten,
dass du selbst gucken kannst, wo er hängt?
Das weiß ich nicht, was man da am besten macht.
Sitzheizungsabo eingeführt.
Kein Scheiß.
Wer einen warmen...
Ja!
Ich sag doch BMW.
Wir hatten es doch am Anfang des Streams vorhin.
Da hab ich doch noch gesagt,
ich glaube, bei BMW kostet es doch schon was, Sitzheizung zu benutzen.
Dann hab ich das schwarz auf weiß eingeführt.
Kein Scheiß.
Wer einen warmen Hintern haben wollte,
musste einfach 17 Euro im Monat latzen,
um die Sitzheizung freizuschalten.
Das gab einen ziemlichen Aufschrei.
Und an alle empörten BMW-Kunden mit Sitzheizungsabo
hat die Renault-Tochter Dacia daraufhin gratis Wärmflaschen verteilt.
Einfach nur, um ein bisschen zu stacheln.
Die ganze Nummer ist BMW dann doch zu heiß geworden
und man hat sich in München wieder von der Idee verabschiedet.
Aber auch wenn BMW in Sachen Abo nicht durchkommt,
aber das ist normal, die loten jetzt einfach aus,
wie weit man das Ganze treiben kann zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt.
Und das muss man auch alle paar Jahre neu machen,
weil irgendwann akzeptieren es die Leute vielleicht.
...durchgezogen hat.
Die Idee hat unsere Art zu konsumieren für immer verändert.
Prio Nummer 1 ist deshalb Überblick behalten in dem ganzen Abo-Wahnsinn.
Dafür gibt es zum Beispiel ziemlich praktische Apps im Abo, selbstverständlich.
Man kann auch einfach eine TXT-Datei machen
und reinschreiben, was man alles abonniert.
Braucht man keine extra App für.
Adobe hat mit seinem Abo-Modell alles auf eine Karte gesetzt und gewonnen.
Mittlerweile zählt der Photoshop-Konzern einfach zu den wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt.
Gleichzeitig sollte das Beispiel Adobe aber auch eine Warnung sein.
Denn mittlerweile besitzt Adobe mit seinem Programm,
zumindest in einigen Bereichen, so was wie ein Monopol.
Und das ist für uns Kunden erstmal nicht so gut.
Erst recht nicht, wenn man beruflich auch noch auf diese Software angewiesen ist.
Was die Abo-Flut im Allgemeinen angeht, bin ich so ein bisschen zwiegespalten.
Auf der einen Seite sind die super bequem und man ist immer auf dem neuesten Stand.
Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich aber nicht, dass mir gefühlt jeder Scheiß im Abo vertickt wird,
den es vorher auch normal zu haben gab.
Der Erfolg dieses Geschäftsmodells, vor allem in den USA, zeigt aber,
dass wir da gerade erst am Anfang stehen.
So, das war unsere Analyse zur Abo-Flut.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Hier findet ihr noch ein Video aus dem Funk-Kosmos.
Und hier ihr Video aus dem Funk-Kosmos.
Und hier gibt es mehr von uns.
Alles klar.
Und wenn ihr uns...
Und tschüss.
Äh, what?
Okay.
Es gibt genug, die das probiert haben und es nicht funktioniert.
Es gibt ja zu Photoshop durchaus, je nach Einsatzzweck, Alternativen.
Ich benutze ja auch Affinity Designer zum Beispiel für Thumbnails und nicht Photoshop und sowas.
Aber insgesamt ist das schon sehr etabliert.
Und im Videoschnittbereich benutzt ja auch keiner wirklich Premiere im professionellen Umfeld.
Oder wenig Premiere.
Das ist eher was für YouTube-Creator und irgendwelche Marketing-Agenturen und sowas.
Aber Filme werden so gut wie nie in Premiere zum Beispiel geschnitten.
Aber trotzdem, dieser ganze Kosmos aus Adobe-Produkten hat schon eine ziemlich große Stellung.
Was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn noch?
Ohne Kleber fürs Klima, das neue hin und her...
Oh nee, please, da habe ich jetzt echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Warum will YouTube unbedingt...
Oh nee, dass ich mir das hier angucke.
Mit was werden dann Filme geschnitten?
Also, Blackmagic ist in diesem Bereich echt ziemlich nice dabei.
Dann gibt es, wie heißt dieses Apple-Ding?
Final Cut oder so machen auch einige.
Und ansonsten, wie die ganzen Filmstudios, was die benutzen, keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall nicht Premiere.
Sehr selten Premiere.
Avid, ja sowas, genau.
Das ist auch sehr beliebt da.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Elon's Brain Chips actually work on humans.
Ah, Fireship-Video.
Fireship ist immer nice.
Nochmal Fireship.
How I deploy serverless containers for free.
Leute, ich wette mit euch, das ist mit Adobe, äh, nicht Adobe, jetzt fängt es schon wieder an.
Mit Oracle Cloud Free Tier.
Könnte ich wetten.
Wobei, ich habe das auch schon mal versucht.
Ich wollte mal das Oracle Free Tier ausprobieren.
Aber da wollten die, dass ich...
Da wollte ich mich mit Kreditkarte und allem registrieren und da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Oh, Weep-Musik, Leute.
Auf, ne, ne, ne, jetzt nicht.
Ich will euch, ich will euch nicht zu sehr quälen.
Gucken wir uns mal das an.
Fireship macht immer nice Videos.
Months ago, Elon Musk announced Neuralink had implanted their first Brain Chip into a real-life human.
Ernsthaft?
Habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
A few months ago, Elon Musk announced Neuralink had implanted their first Brain Chip into a real-life human.
But in the weeks that followed...
Ich frage mich, wer das freiwillig macht.
Na gut, wobei.
Doch, frage ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Gibt es genug Freiwillige?
Es gibt ja auch genug Freiwillige, die sich auf den Mars schicken lassen wollten und sowas.
...we heard nothing but crickets.
Based on the prior testing results with monkeys,
doctors, scientists and Elon-Haters all over the world feared the worst.
They assumed the Encephalon likely exploded and patient zero did not survive.
Finally, yesterday, we learned the truth.
The Neuralink install was a success and the results are absolutely mind-blowing.
First ever user of the Neuralink device.
And I think...
You're my only telekinetic friend that I have.
Yeah, I hope so.
It is March 21st, 2024 and you're watching The Code Report.
This is Nolan Arbaugh.
He's a 29-year-old who was paralyzed from the shoulder down in a diving accident.
That's not the best car to be dealt in life, but over the last few weeks, he's gained telekinetic-like abilities that seem...
Ich habe jetzt mal eine Frage.
Wie schafft man das?
Also, wie wird man querschnittsgelähmt vom Tauchen?
Was muss da passieren?
Also, bei Stürzen und so...
Kann ich mir das vorstellen?
Aber beim Tauchen?
Was muss da passieren?
Wir sehen ja, dass es funktioniert, aber...
Sauerstoffmangel?
Okay, Sauerstoffmangel, Gehirnschäden und dann...
Ja, gut, vielleicht, ja.
Verkehrsunfall mit U-Boot.
Ja, sicherlich das wahrscheinlichste Szenario.
...possible at first glance.
Like here he's controlling a mouse cursor to play games like chess and Civ VI using nothing but his thoughts.
There's no eye tracking or sensors other than the chip in his brain.
In today's video, we'll find out exactly...
...how this crazy technology works and make some predictions about where things are going in the future.
But first, I think humanity owes this guy a huge amount of respect and appreciation.
The average person thinks they're brave for being an early adopter of the Cybertruck,
but it takes real balls of stainless steel to order the Foundation Series Neuralink.
What's crazy is that the chip itself is not installed by a human surgeon, but rather a surgical robot.
After drilling a hole into your cranium, it implants a bunch of tiny threads that are finer than a human hair.
It uses a tiny needle like a sewing machine to weave these threads into your brain.
Each thread contains high-density electrodes, which are capable of detecting electrical activity, also known as brain waves.
Wann lässt du dich chippen?
War das nicht so, dass uns Bill Gates mit der Corona-Impfung schon alle heimlich gechippt hat?
...has 1024 electrodes distributed across 64 threads...
...which means you have 16 electrodes per...
Moment, jetzt hab ich jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
...of detecting electrical activity, also known as brain waves.
The N1 chip has 1024 electrodes distributed across 64 threads.
Das bedeutet, dass du 16 Elektroden pro Thread hast.
Um das in Perspektive zu stellen,
hat ein typischer Elektroencephalogramm
ca. 20 Sensoren
und sie maximieren meistens ca. 256 Elektroden.
Zudem sind sie auf der Außenseite deines Schuhs,
was bedeutet, dass du mehr möglich bist,
Interferenz zu bekommen, bevor das Signal
das Elektrode erreicht.
Der einzige echte Vorteil ist,
dass du nicht ein Loch in deinem Schuh drillen musst.
Der N1 transmittet Daten unabhängig
und ist mit einer kleinen Lithium-Ion-Batterie gesteuert.
Und diese Batterie wird unabhängig von außen
durch die N1-Sensoren ausgeliefert.
Geil! Musst du dir dein Ladegerät am Kopf halten!
Der N1 transmittet Daten unabhängig
und ist mit einer kleinen Lithium-Ion-Batterie gesteuert.
Und das ist das, was wir am meisten interessiert sind beim Messen,
weil wir bestimmte Wave-Pattern erkennen können,
wie z.B. eine Sound-Wave,
die einen bestimmten Gedanken in deinem Gehirn identifizieren kann.
Sie bieten nicht viel Detail in dem Neuralink-Video,
aber er könnte einen Gedanken haben,
wie z.B. move my right arm,
der einen bestimmten typischen elektrischen Signal in seinem Gehirn erzeugt.
Der Chip selbst kann dann darauf hinkommen,
was eine Aktion ermöglicht,
den Maus nach rechts zu bewegen.
Aber das passiert nicht nach dem Arzt.
Es gibt eine Gehirn-Computer-Interface,
weil alle Gehirn-Wave anders sind
und es muss lernen, welche Gedanken
zu welchen Bewegungen korrespondieren.
Wenn du arme Arme und Beine hast,
kannst du nicht so aufgeregt sein,
aber für viele könnte diese Technologie lebendig sein,
besonders wenn sie mit zukünftigen Technologien integriert ist.
Wie heute haben wir Fahrräder,
aber in der nicht so nahen Zukunft
könnten sie von Mech-Suits verwendet werden,
die von der Person im Gehirn kontrolliert sind.
Ich weiß, das klingt verrückt,
aber die Robotik-Fielde ist auch gerade aufgewachsen.
Figur 1 hat unglaubliche menschliche Dexterität
und Nvidia hat gerade ihre eigenen menschlichen Roboter eröffnet,
bevor es einen Apple-Robot Pro gibt.
Wenn Gehirn-Wave und Robotik in der nahen Zukunft verwendet werden,
können Menschen mit Behinderungen
viel weniger beschränkt werden,
und das ist ein großer Wunsch für die Menschheit.
Gehirn-Wave haben ihre Skeptiker,
für offensichtliche Gründe,
aber glücklicherweise fliegt die Daten nur auf eine Art und Weise.
Du musst dich nicht überlegen,
KFC-Anleitungen in deine Träume zu werfen
und sie werden keine wichtigen körperlichen Funktionen
auslösen können, wenn du dein Monatsabschluss nicht bezahlst.
Sie können auch nicht wirklich
hochkomplexe Gedanken identifizieren,
was bedeutet, dass es keine Frage ist,
ob es eine API für JavaScript-Developer gibt,
um Apps zu bauen.
Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
SpaceX fliegt auch mit
JavaScript und Elektron
ins Weltall.
In's Weltall.
Schreibt es mir,
wenn ihr nicht sterben wollt.
Das war's für den Code-Report.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Was ist aus Battlebit geworden?
Gute Frage.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Sehe ich da PHP?
Ist das PHP?
Das sieht so hässlich und wie aus
mit den Dollars.
Das ist doch PHP, oder?
Leiser.
Was ist dein Favorite?
Ne, ich hab's nicht in nem Bart gemacht.
Ich hab's mit
äh
Drop-on gemacht.
Mit drauf-trauftröpfeln.
Was ist dein Favorite Reverse-Proxy?
Das ist eine sehr gute, eine nahezu
exzellente Frage.
In welchem Kontext? Ich kann dir das beantworten.
Mein Allround-Lieblings-
Reverse-Proxy ist
Nginx. Für
einfache Sachen ist es
Cudi und im Kubernetes-Umfeld
ist es auch Nginx.
Für customizable
Sachen, wo man spezielle Health-
Checks und sowas braucht, HA-Proxy.
Was ich nicht mag, ist Traffic
und Apache
oder Internet-Information-Service.
Server?
Wie heißt das überhaupt?
Wobei, kann man damit überhaupt gescheit
Reverse-Proxy? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Benutzt doch irgendjemand
IES. Also Traffic
mag ich nicht, Cudi mag ich auch.
Apache mag ich auch nicht.
Und hab ich noch was vergessen?
Ich mein, im Kubernetes-Umfeld,
gibt's enorm viel anderes Zeug noch
dafür.
Aber...
Also auch mit
Loadbalancing-Funktionen und allem.
Aber ich glaub, das war's
so im Großen und Ganzen, was da
verbreitet ist.
Gibt Kunden, die unbedingt IES nutzen wollen?
Ja, man versteht manchmal die Leute auch
nicht.
Nginx-Proxy-Manager hat jetzt aber nur
sekundär was mit Reverse-Proxy zu tun. Das ist
ein Web-Interface, um Nginx
als Reverse-Proxy zu konfigurieren,
inklusive Let's Encrypt-Zertifikats-Handling.
Istio ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Istio ist ein Service-Mesh.
Da kannst du beispielsweise
gucken, wie der Traffic
von Container zu Container fließt
und so Zeug.
Istio ist ein Service.
Sowas wie LinkAD zum Beispiel.
Ist auch ein Service-Mesh.
Da kannst du auch relativ easy
mTLS machen. Also sprich
verschlüsselte Kommunikation zu
Containern.
Weil die Container dann quasi nicht
mehr so direkt miteinander reden,
sondern automatisch connected werden
über das Service-Mesh und so.
Da hast du dann quasi so ein Sidecar-Container,
was Verschlüsselung macht.
Dann ist dann die In-Cluster-Kommunikation
verschlüsselt mit mTLS.
Sowas kannst du damit machen. Istio ist
kein Nginx-Reverse-Proxy-Ersatz.
Der Standard
Kubernetes-
Ingress ist ja auch auf Nginx-Basis.
Und wohlgemerkt,
Nginx-Ingress ist was anderes
wie Ingress-Nginx,
weil die Benahmung mal wieder kacke ist.
Was hat NPM
mit Docker-Networks zu tun?
Diese drei Sachen
ergeben für mich jetzt absolut
keinen Sinn zusammen.
Für euch, Chatge.
NPM ist der Package-Manager von Node.js.
Docker-Network ist das eine.
Okay, Unraid. Aber was hat
Imich damit jetzt zu tun?
Das ist ein Service, den du in Docker
laufen lassen würdest vielleicht.
Ach, Nginx-Proxy-Manager.
Ach so.
Ja, das ist
eine Unraid-Konfigurations-Sache.
Gar nicht, oder?
Brauchst du nicht.
Das Ding braucht mehrere
Netzwerk-Interfaces.
Der Container bräuchte mehrere
Netzwerkkarten,
die in unterschiedlichen Netzen hängen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich hatte gestern
seit Ewigkeiten mal wieder
einen Stromausfall.
Und ich habe das dadurch gemerkt,
dass
meine ganzen Steckdosen,
meine ganzen smarten Steckdosen geplinkt haben,
weil die nicht mehr zu ihrem MQTT
Video, äh Video, zu ihrem
MQTT-Server gekommen sind.
Muss aber nur ganz kurzer Stromausfall gewesen
sein, weil manche Sachen sind
eindeutig weitergelaufen, aber die Raspberry Pi
sind beispielsweise auch abgekackt.
Und übrigens, diese Steckdosenleisten,
die ich hier ein paar mal geflasht habe im Stream,
ich habe nicht die von
Hammer, aber das ist die, die gibt es von
Hammer.
Ja, die da.
Die gibt es, das ist China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleiste.
Die gibt es von 50 verschiedenen
Herstellern. Und die
hatte lange Zeit einen ESP2866
drin, dass du die Custom
Firmware flashen kannst. Davon
sind mir jetzt innerhalb von einer Woche drei
Stück kaputt gegangen. Eine
im Keller gestern beim Stromausfall,
eine hier, wo mein Rechner dranhängt,
und die, die ich hier neben mir liegen
habe mit Ladegeräten dran, wo mein
Ring-Light ist, wenn ich mal was streamen
muss mit Bastel-Kram.
In einer Woche drei Stück.
Die sind halt auch ungefähr alle gleich alt.
Ich bin mir halt jetzt
unschlüssig. Ist es ein Fehler
von den Steckdosenleisten? Also ja, ist es
auf jeden Fall. Oder
ist irgendwas mit meinem Stromnetz daheim
im Arsch, dass die Dinger das einfach
nur, weil die fragil sind, das als erstes
merken? Drei Stück innerhalb
von einer Woche oder eineinhalb Wochen sind mir da
jetzt verreckt. Wobei ich glaube,
die Steckdosenleiste ist einfach im Arsch.
Das ist wie
kaputt? Wenn du sie in Strom
steckst... Nee, aufgeschraubt habe ich
die nicht. Ja, ich könnte mal reingucken tatsächlich, ob
da irgendwas verkohlt ist oder so, ja.
Ähm, also
wenn du sie in Strom steckst,
ja, die sind über ein Jahr alt, meine.
Meine sind schon drei Jahre oder
so alt, wie die jetzt
kaputt gegangen sind. Also
mal gespannt, wie lange deine noch halten.
Also was
mit der Steckdosenleiste jetzt passiert ist, wenn du sie
jetzt in Strom steckst,
dann gehen die Lichter nicht mehr an, die LEDs,
was so viel heißt, wie der
Microcontroller da drin wird
auch nicht mehr mit Strom versorgt.
Und dementsprechend schalten da auch
keine Relays und nix mehr.
Und die Steckdosenleiste geht halt einfach nicht mehr.
Eventuell haben die einen Überspannungsschutz,
den du resetten musst.
Haben die nicht, oder?
Nee, sowas haben die nicht.
Das ist nicht so.
Die sind nicht so advanced.
Kein Überspannungsschutz, den man hier resetten
kann. Den ESP könnte man
wechseln. Ich glaube nicht, dass es am
ESP selber liegt.
Ich glaube, dass da drinnen irgendwas
kaputt gegangen ist und
dadurch der ESP zerstört wurde.
Also sprich, selbst wenn man da jetzt den neuen
ESP reinmacht und nochmal das
Motor drauf flasht, dann wird er
wahrscheinlich auch wieder instant kaputt gehen.
Also
sadge.
Kaputt.
Ich deck die jetzt nochmal rein und dann
gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Wahrscheinlich nix.
Nee, nix.
Dead.
Komplett dead.
Das Ding.
Deadge.
Macht einfach gar nix mehr.
Deadge. Sadge.
Kann ich wieder rausziehen.
Ich glaube, das war's mit China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleisten.
Ich werd mir irgendwie noch ne normale wieder hinstellen.
Aber es ist schon verdächtig, dass
drei Stück innerhalb von 1,5 Wochen verreckt sind, oder?
An's Trinken erinnern, ja.
Nein, heute
keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute Spaghetti, Tomatensohsargfleisch.
Telefonieren die
nach draußen? Ja, wenn du die mit
Standard-China-Firmware betreibst, eventuell.
Aber ich betreib die ja nicht
mit Standard-China-Firmware. Ich hab die ja
geflasht mit Tasmota.
Und das telefoniert
garantiert nicht nach draußen. Zumal ich die
auch noch zusätzlich in meinem IoT
WLAN hängen hab.
Was nur Zugriff, also was kein Internetzugriff
hat, was nur Zugriff
auf meinen MQTT-Server hat
und sonst nix.
Und auf NTP für
Zeit, Uhrzeit.
Tasmota hängt übrigens, wenn es keinen Zugriff auf
NTP hat. Ist auch
Ding, was ich lernen musste, was nirgendswo steht.
Wird Tasmota eigentlich noch weiterentwickelt?
Hat schon lange, lange nix mehr
mitgemacht.
Ja.
13.4
Weißt du.
Chat, was machen wir denn jetzt noch?
Irgendwas Gutes, was wir noch gucken können?
Ich krieg übelst Hunger gerade schon.
Aber ich bin ja auch erst so spät on gekommen.
Wollen wir noch
ein FireShip-Video gucken?
Mach das mal. Hast du übrigens mitbekommen,
bei den Fritzboxen mit den...
Ja, hab ich mitbekommen. Ja, ja, das kenn ich.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Ja. Das kenn ich. Das war
so ne NFT-Handel-Seite
oder sowas, wo man bei
fritz.box rausgekommen ist. Wobei
die, glaube ich, mittlerweile abgeschaltet wurde.
Moment.
3-4 Gigabyte Traffic am
Tag? Was macht die
Waschmaschine denn da?
Das ist ja schon enorm.
Ich mein, nicht Internet-Traffic
einfach wie... Wobei,
ja wohin soll's denn sonst was schicken?
3-4 Gigabyte am Tag.
Das ist enorm viel, man.
Hast du mal irgendwie
mitgeschnitten, was die macht?
War schon wahrscheinlich
verschlüsselt, oder?
Aber du müsstest zumindest
sehen, wohin die connectet.
Downloaded Wasser.
Ist ja ganz weird.
Ich glaube, das liegt auch daran...
Ich würde
den Herstellern nicht mal böse Absichten
unbedingt unterstellen. Ich glaube,
gerade von diesen Dingern ist auch sehr viel
unfähig programmiert.
Vielleicht meint die ja Kryptogramm.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich geh jetzt was fressen. Ich hab Hunger.
Heute kein Lachs mit Nudel.
User of LG
Washing Machine spotted the
11 Giga
Bit
of Traffic.
What the fuck?
Was macht das Ding da, Alter?
Kam da irgendwas raus bei dem Thread?
Was machen die da?
Man hat keinerlei Zugriff auf das Gerät.
Deswegen wird das auch
ähm...
schwierig zu Man in the Middlen.
Simple Explanation.
Internet of Shits.
Das ist auch ein nicer Account.
Den lese ich auch öfter.
So wirklich was rausbekommen
hat man da jetzt aber auch nicht, oder?
Das ist schon ein ziemlicher Fail.
Ich glaube, so Sachen sind auch oftmals
sehr...
flüchtig
und mies programmiert.
Also ich hab
.zip komplett
in meinem Router als Domains.
.zip wird bei mir einfach
default nicht aufgelöst.
Hab ich gemacht an dem Tag,
als die .zip Domains live gingen.
Ist, finde ich, eines der unnötigsten Moves
gewesen überhaupt.
.zip als Domain.
Okay. Alles klar, Leute.
Ich geh
jetzt was fressen.
Bis später. Macht's gut.
See you.